[Musique]
nous sommes à la ligne d'arrivée les
chefs ont assez parlé ils attendent
votre réponse bienvenue à votre soirée
électorale
[Musique]
bonsoir madame et Messieurs ici Patrice
roi toute l'équipe de l'information de
Radio-Canada en direct de l'Atrium de
cette nouvelle Maison de Radio-Canada
Sébastien Beauvais bonsoir
on est toujours fébrile on a hâte
d'avoir les premiers résultats c'est
dans une heure et demie je vais vous
poser la question à tous la même
qu'est-ce que vous surveillez
particulièrement plusieurs régions moi
ma région chouchou c'est l'Est du Québec
je vais vous en parler dans un instant
mais c'est la bataille de la survie pour
le Parti québécois notamment donc je
surveille ça et plusieurs autres
circonscriptions à travers le Québec
sont à surveiller oui Chantal Hébert
bonsoir merci d'être là surveillez quoi
ce soir Camille Lauren parce que c'est
pas seulement la survie du Parti
québécois c'est le besoin pour le Parti
québécois d'avoir un chef à l'Assemblée
nationale
la survie et le retour en force c'est
parti passe par là donc à surveiller
c'est un gros pagri pour pas de
Saint-Pierre Plamondon de se présenter
là
sur l'île de Montréal ou le PQ va pas si
bien que ça donc c'est une des boîtes à
surprises de la soirée et d'ailleurs ça
fait longtemps moi je ne me souviens pas
d'une soirée électorale où la région de
Montréal est aussi intéressante que ce
soit à la question gay bonsoir beaucoup
de belles batailles régionales l'île de
Montréal aussi moi je vais surveiller
l'esprit Québec solidaire dans
Sherbrooke dans Saint-François la petite
circonscription à côté de Sherbrooke ça
peut donner l'idée de la soirée que
Québec solidaire va avoir la bataille
dans Sherbrooke contre la calque dans
Saint-François aussi parmi bien d'autres
circonscriptions à surveiller mais
l'esprit je vais surveiller ça du point
de l’œil et nous serons bien sûr
beaucoup sur le terrain dans toutes les
régions du Québec et parlant de tout le
Québec on a décidé d'emmener une partie
de Québec une partie de Montréal une
partie des régions sur le plateau ici
incarnez par Regis Labeaume exmère de
Québec c'est la bonsoir bonsoir
m'annoncer mais reste actuelle vous
n'êtes pas une vraie mais reste actuelle
de chibougamo oui monsieur merci d'être
là on s'est parlé lors du déclenchement
puis à plusieurs reprises et Luc
Ferrandez
roi mère du Plateau
Mont-Royal merci d'être là
je vous pose la même question vous
surveillez quoi rapidement ce soir ben
écoutez le lieu de naissance des
conservateurs c'est la région de Québec
les puissantes est là à moitié de
surprise ailleurs il faudrait savoir si
on a soulevé le soldat duem d'un
Chauveau et si ailleurs entre autres la
bataille des poulets dans vos Sud si je
passe quelque chose de sérieux alors
c'est ça mon lieu d'intérêt très bien
m'annoncer
j'aimerais saluer les gens de leur
appeler quand encore quelques heures
pour aller voter surtout qu'il fait beau
cette année et je vais surveiller par
ailleurs ou un Noranda Témiscaming je
pense que avec ce qui s'est passé avec
la fonderie les derniers événements des
derniers jours des dernières semaines
donc je pense ça va être une lutte on
est là pour une belle soirée je
comprends
Rouen c'est imprévisible monsieur
Legault a dit vous avez rencontré
Monsieur le goût à quelques jours samedi
matin comme mairesse et il a dit les
gens de Rouen vont décider on a devoir
ça Luc Verdun vers 2 c'est une bataille
dentiste qui sont ils sont nés à ni tous
les trois avec la même score d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui néanmier Isabelle Mélenchon
qui était relégué aux oubliettes qui a
réussi à remonté à fort à la force des
poignets et qui maintenant fait face à
Québec soldat qui veut absolument gagner
en fait les trois parties la carte
Québec solidaire
de la partie libérale ne peuvent pas
perdre s'il perdent d'un Verdun les
trois perdent un symbole important
partie libéral serait la démonstration
qui peuvent pas gagner dans un comté qui
est à 60% francophone ils veulent avoir
sont pas capables de prendre prise sur
Montréal et ça ne pas avoir de prix sur
Montréal c'est un drame de la soirée de
ce soir il faut il y avait quelques
endroits il pourrait prendre prise
Maurice Richard Verdun rivière des
Prairies en jours réelles il y avait mis
des ils ont mis des bons candidats donc
très important on ira partout tout ce
que vous avez nommé on va y aller en
direct effectivement c'est des luttes à
suivre pendant qu'on voit des gens qui
continuent à voter alors la grande
question à cette heure-ci c'est ce que
les gens sont allés voter est-ce que il
y a eu un taux de participation à la
hauteur c'est un peu plus élevé on va le
voir dans le tableau plus élevé que la
dernière fois le vote par anticipation
avait été pas mal plus élevé et le vote
à cette heure-ci est plus élevé qu'en
2018 alors qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur
le résultat final avoir chacun des
expériences différentes
moi je suis allé voter ce matin il y
avait pas un chat d'autres m'ont dit
c'était plein
des lieux donc le vote participation
c'est
le taux de participation actuellement
44%, le vote à anticipation en 2022 donc
cette année a été le plus fort depuis
qu'on enregistre le vote par
anticipation est-ce que c'est plus une
affaire de logistique familiale qu'on va
voter par anticipation que plutôt de
dire que on le taux de participation va
augmenter ce soir il est à 44,6 en ce
moment on aura un dernier chiffre
évidemment dans le courant de la soie il
était pour les gens qui adorent les
chiffres il était à 41 très exactement
il y a quatre ans donc une petite
poussée faut voir il y a
6 millions
30113 personnes très exactement qui sont
inscrits sur la liste électorale au
Québec il y a 810 candidats que l'on
salue d'ailleurs pour reprendre
l'expression populaire au Québec là ils
ont mis leur face sur le poteau la
dissolution la ligne de départ la voici
76 pour la CAQ 27 pour le Parti libéral
10 pour Québec solidaires le PQ 7 il y a
quatre indépendants et un pour le une
devrait-je dire pour le Parti
conservateur du Québec je vous rappelle
que pour avoir la majorité c'est le
chiffre magique de 63 qu'un des parties
doit atteindre Mathieu proche vous êtes
dans le bureau de vote de Verdun Luc
parlait de Verdun alors comment ça se
passe
il n'y a pas eu de fil pendant les
quelques heures qu'on a passé ici
effectivement devant ce bureau d'autre
pas de fil en moyenne je vous dirais que
tout le processus pour chaque électeur
prend à peu près deux ou trois minutes
en moyenne mais ça défile
continuellement derrière nous et Luc
effectivement le disait Verdun c'est
pourtant un endroit où chaque voix
chaque voix des lecteur va compter parce
que trois parties sont littéralement nés
à nez dans les dernières intentions de
votre KIA il y avait des inquiétudes sur
l'organisation du scrutin dans plusieurs
circonscriptions à l'échelle du Québec
ont circonscription dont trois étaient
ici sur l'île de Montréal pourquoi parce
qu'on pensait qu'ils ont manquerait
peut-être de personnel et on a travaillé
très très fort dans les derniers jours
cette fin de semaine pour recruter du
personnel ici dans Verdun jusqu'à hier
on a formé des personnes alors comment
on s'est arrangé normalement vous savez
ce duo de scrutateur et secrétaire
s'occupe d'une seule boîte de scrutin
alors dans certains cas et bien on a
poussé ça à deux donc on a doublé la
charge de travail mais comme je le dis
c'était vraiment très très fluide taux
de participation ici dans Verdun à 16
heures 47% donc un petit peu plus élevé
que la moyenne nationale que vous avez
évoquée c'était 32% à 12h30 puis ça ça
inclus évidemment le vote par
anticipation des 7 autres journées qui
ont eu lieu donc de 24 et quelques
pourcents pourquoi la participation
Patrice est importante évidemment pour
la santé démocratique de cette société
mais de manière plus prosaïque c'est
aussi pour la santé financière des
partis pourquoi parce que chaque
électeur ça représente 1 dollar 71
aujourd'hui en 2022 de financement pour
les parties alors on va en entendre des
électeurs vous savez il y a aussi des
petits électeurs parce qu'il y a un
programme électeur en herbe qui permet
aux enfants de se prononcer pas sur les
programmes mais sur certains choix de
société alors c'est ce que ce dont nous
parle un des pères qui est cet électeur
que j'ai interviewé en premier
c'était vraiment bien le petit va-t'on
en famille je sais pas si vous avez vu
de mise à part il y a une petite blague
maintenant il y a une belle initiative
où les enfants peuvent voter c'est super
bien mais sinon pourquoi voter c'est
important c'est un devoir je pense que
c'est important parce qu'après ben on
peut pas rien on peut pas chialer donc
si vous voulez Charlie ben allez votre
je pourrais pas dire qu'un parti qui m'a
plu plus plus qu'un autre par contre
c'est un peu difficile de faire le choix
puis ça m'a pris beaucoup de temps de
décider si tout le monde le fond ça fait
une différence
mais si chacun individu pense que
se dit dans un malheur mais on va jamais
voir une différence
alors c'est une des raisons que moi très
bien alors on verra si on va dépasser le
taux de participation et plus tard dans
la soirée bientôt on va parler
directement général des élections
d'ailleurs pénurie de main d'oeuvre
d'une part comment ça s'est passé
aujourd'hui etc le vote par anticipation
ça c'est une question très intéressante
pour ceux qui sont derrière qui doivent
faire des projections électorales de
votre part
[Musique]
2018 parce que la coalition Québec a
pris deux circonscriptions la bataille
elle se fait où ce soir elle se fait ici
dans des circonscriptions comme Maurice
Richard notamment juste ici
voilà Maurice Richard qui apparaît
Verdun aussi Québec solidaire la
coalition à Québec espère faire des
gains là le Parti libéral espère sauver
ses mains d'où donc l'importance de
Montréal ce soir d'autres régions qu'on
surveillent particulièrement je pense
que la base c'est pas votre région c'est
une de mes régions chouchou Laval est-ce
que les libéraux vont conserver leur
circonscription combien ils vont en
perdre alors il y a combien de
circonscriptions à Laval il y en a 6 il
y en a combien qui appartiennent au
libéraux 5 à la fin de la soirée la
coalition va venir Québec espère
renverser ce résultat et avoir cinq
circonscriptions si la carte peut faire
des gains sur le Parti libéral c'est
dans la région de Laval je vous amène
dans la région de Monsieur Labeau
qui est aussi ma région
pas mal de bleu pound bleu de la
coalition Québec il y a deux
circonscriptions qui sont à Québec
solidaires Jean Lesage et Tachereau mais
celle qu'on va surveiller
particulièrement ce soir c'est Chauveau
pourquoi parce que le chef du Parti
conservateur Éric dumm s'y présente une
autre circonscription consommée sur la
Rive-Sud
les militants du parti conservateur ont
dit à iridien on n'a pas besoin de toi
dans la campagne ça va tellement bien il
est quand même passé par bosnord
dimanche en espérant mobiliser ces
troupes et beau Sud la bataille des
poulains il y a trois candidats qui
s'appellent poulain dans cette
circonscription ce sont les trois
circonscriptions qu'on va surveiller
dans la grande région de Québec et je
termine par ma région chouchou vu que
c'est moi qui contrôle le tableau en
fait c'est pas top c'est pas tant gaspés
c'est pas tant bas c'est la langue
Gaspésie mais tout l'Est du Québec il y
a combien de circonscriptions dans les
du Québec il y en a 9 combien
appartiennent au Parti québécois 8 ça
veut dire que ça passe ou ça casse pour
le Parti québécois la coalition Québec a
des espoirs de faire des gains dans
cette région Québec solidaire aussi
pourquoi il y aurait une plateauisation
de la Gaspésie
anglaise peut-être pas d'accord mais il
y a des gens de la ville qui sont
arrivés en Gaspésie notamment dans le
circonscription de bonne aventure ici
celle de Gaspé qui donne espoir à Québec
solidaire parce que ça va se
matérialiser ce soir faudra bien voir et
en terminant vous vous dites Sébastien
bave et dit n'importe quoi je vais faire
ma propre carte électorale ce soir je
vais jouer moi Sébastien Bobet vous
pouvez le faire sur le site de
Radio-Canada donc vous avez la carte
électorale il y a pas de couleur parce
que les résultats sont pas encore
arrivés vous pouvez aussi vous trouver
des circonscriptions que vous voulez
surveiller donc par exemple Anjou Louis
Riel sur l'île de Montréal qui est une
circonscription qu'on va surveiller des
candidats que vous voulez suivre ici on
a mis les cinq chefs pour que vous
puissiez lécher les suivre c'est vous
qui faites les choix en passant et vous
favoris aussi donc vous pouvez choisir
une circonscription favorite et suivre
donc trouver que je parle pas assez de
votre circonscription par exemple vous
pouvez suivre en temps réel votre
description et jouer à ce que je fais
moi sur ce plateau c'est fascinant parce
que vous expliquiez ça et déjà nous
inviter ce soir donc c'est réglé mais
c'est un site je le rappelle à chaque
fois qui est vraiment très agréable très
facile d'accès qu'on peut faire sa liste
électorale avec vous le connaissez bien
aussi absolument puis ça permet d'avoir
donc plusieurs circonscriptions qu'on
surveille en même temps parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de belles batailles ce soir on
parle de qui va former le gouvernement
oui c'est important mais la dynamique de
l'Assemblée nationale va être transformé
à chaque élection c'est le cas donc
est-ce qu'on va voir davantage de ce
qu'on va des conservateurs pour la
première fois est-ce qu'on va avoir
davantage de Québec solidaire est-ce que
le PQ va garder ses circonscriptions ça
il va y avoir une influence sur les
quatre prochaines années et donc vous
pouvez suivre ça aller chercher les
circonscriptions qui vous qui qui sont
d'intérêt puis on va pouvoir suivre sur
la soirée et globalement aussi plus
profondément la question qu'on se pose
Chantal c'est est-ce que on a redessiné
la carte électorale en 2018 au Québec
avec la CAQ est-ce que on fait un pas de
plus aujourd'hui ou ça reste avec cinq
parties politiques comme ça est-ce qu'on
est un entre deux à quelle mesure on va
avancer ou pas dans cette direction
d'abord le fait que 5 que partie qui
sont donc quatre sont à peu près à
égalité ce que ça dit c'est qu'on n'est
pas en train de revenir en arrière si on
est en train de revenir en arrière on
dirait le PQ va peut-être revenir une
partie libérale on n'est pas du tout
dans cette dynamique là donc on est
selon moi encore dans une période de
transition et quand on regarde la
dynamique de la campagne ce qu'on peut
se dire c'est que 2018 c'était pas un
accident une tocade un peu comme la
bague orange en 2011 qui a passé puis
que laisser quelques petits morceaux de
sable c'est pas ça du tout
la balance la coalition à venir Québec
ce serait la première fois si François
Legault l'emporte ce serait la première
fois depuis 2008 qu'on garde le même
parti au gouvernement deux fois de suite
ce qu'on faisait toujours avant
bonsoir mais ça me fait plaisir d'être
avec vous monsieur monsieur Roy parlons
du taux de participation donc 17h30
45% c'est mieux qu'en 2018 n'est-ce pas
c'est mieux c'est à peu près 5% de plus
quand 2018 ça avait été c'est la même
chose pour le vote par anticipation qui
est après de 18 là on était près de
25%, est-ce que la tendance va se
maintenir pour le reste de la soirée
c'est ce que nous verrons après après
20h quand les bureaux vont fermer que le
dépouillement va commencer parce que
évidemment le souhait d'à peu près tout
le monde c'est que le taux augmente par
rapport à la dernière fois là
absolument dans 2018 c'est un taux de 60
et un peu plus que 60 et 6%, c'était le
taux le plus faible hormis celui de
décembre 2008 où on avait eu un tour on
était en décembre ça peut se comprendre
à de 56 ou 57 %. mais le taux de 85 de
toute personne baisse le des 80 % on ne
connaissant 94 et en 76 mais là on est
vraiment dans le 75 ça descend là
70 très bien monsieur ride la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre vous aviez une poignée de
sa construction où c'était un problème
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé là aujourd'hui
ben oui effectivement depuis quelques
jours il y avait 11 circonscriptions qui
étaient en disant en pénurie de main
d'oeuvre à la suite de désistement pour
certains à cause de la covid mais on
nous avons réussi quand même à combler
des postes et ajouter des substituts en
cas de d'absence ce matin il reste deux
circuits il y a deux circonscriptions où
on n'a pas réussi à combler donc on a
demandé à des équipes de scrutateurs de
sécurité d'avoir la responsabilité de
deux bureaux de vote donc dans d'artémie
Guy il y a 16 équipes qui vont assumer
les responsables de deux bureaux de vote
et aussi dans hall ou C6 de scrutateurs
et secrétaire vont assumer deux bureaux
de vote mais donc
on ne verra pas de différence
vous devriez pas non en avoir de
différence c'est sûr que pour le
dépouillement ça serait peut-être un peu
plus long mais dans l'ensemble tous des
routes bien de ça devrait se dérouler
comme ça jusqu'à 20h parlons du
déroulement il y a pas eu de
microche il y a pas eu de pépins majeur
il y a une de vos directrices
dans coin qui a fait un peu de zèle
n'est-ce pas ce qu'on a fait un
passeport thème de ça
en fait oui bah il faut savoir que nous
autorisons la prise d'image
sur le lieu de vote parce que même
lorsque les candidats déposent même tout
candidat ça peut être tout candidat qui
est dans sa circonscription et ça c'est
on est entièrement d'accord avec ça bien
sûr ça fait partie de méga démocratie ça
fait partie de la couverture des
élections en même temps les électeurs de
scrutin se doivent d'assurer le bon
déroulement du vote des électeurs dans
leur circonscriptions ils ont le
latitude pour ça en même temps moi je
vous dis que cet après-midi j'étais un
peu regardé ça je pense que les règles
devront être revu réévaluer parce que
pour son équité là quant à la couverture
médiatique pour tous les candidats et
moi je vous je profite l'occasion
monsieur Roy pour écouter c'est comme
directeur général des élections
générales de la responsabilité et je
suis désolé de la situation de ce matin
et je présente mes excuses au
journaliste qui était présent mais c'est
pas tellement les ben oui vous êtes
gentil pour les journées c'est mais
c'est le chef
on n'a pas eu les images de Gabriel ado
Dubois en train de voter donc une
certaine iniquité là mais vous allez
comme parce que c'était une tradition il
y avait pas de règle écrite ce que je
comprends c'est que vous allez mettre
des règles de dire pour les Chefs vous
avez droit de laisser entrer les
journalistes puis on veut pas câbler la
dame pendant ça sept ans non plus elle
voulait bien faire mais donc c'est mal
tombé
plus plus fondamental c'était une bonne
intention ouais je comprends le vote
parenticipation qui a été important
notamment dans la région de Québec
comment vous comptez ça là ce que vous
le comptez d'un coup tout de suite
depuis quelques minutes
le vote par anticipation va débuter vers
18h ce soir donc dans chaque
circonscription il y a des équipes qui
sont affectées au dépouillement du vote
par anticipation habituellement c'est
les premiers résultats que vous voyez
que qui sont affichés bien sûr en raison
du haut taux de participation on peut
s'attendre à ce qui est des délais moi
je dois vous avouer que d'avoir des
résultats avant
20h45 ce serait surprenant mais nos
équipes vont être à l'oeuvre pour faire
le dépouillement ok donc tout les
premiers résultats pour qu'on soit clair
vous serez qui vont sortir ça sera le
vote par anticipation
oui parce que c'est un vote qui débute
déjà et comme je vous disais en raison
du auto c'est sûr que ça peut prendre un
peu plus de temps donc mais comme je
vous dis faut pas trop compter tant
mieux si des résultats qui sont avant
mais disons qu'on comptait pas dans
20h45 d'accord très bien monsieur merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé bonne
soirée électorale à vous
mais à vous de même bonne soirée
électoral merci très bien sur le terrain
depuis le début de cette campagne depuis
le 22 août lors du déclenchement nos
caravaniers suivent les chefs Véronique
prince est avec laque alexandre Duval
avec le Parti libéral Valérie Gamache
avec Québec solidaire on a Sébastien
Desrosiers qui est avec le Parti
québécois et Jean-Claude richardonneau
finalement avec le Parti conservateur
bonsoir On va souvent aller vous voir
bonsoir à vous cinq
Véronique vous êtes au théâtre Capitole
à Québec avec la CAQ j'imagine que dans
la toile je me suis le goût on se disait
bon ben et tant que ça finisse là
effectivement je pense qu'on le sentait
pas mal qu'ils avaient hâte que ça se
termine mais aujourd'hui monsieur Lego
était quand même de bonne humeur je
dirais on est à Québec devant le
Capitole comment 2018 mais en 2018
c'était un tout autre contexte à ce
moment-là la CAQ était beaucoup plus en
mode offensif en se disant les 11 côtés
de Québec on est capable d'aller
chercher tous ceux-là des libéraux et
finalement ils ont réussi à remporter 8
ou 11 en 2018 l'autre contexte c'est
vraiment différent parce que cette
fois-ci on est plus en mode défensif
dans la grande région de Québec
particulièrement Chauveau beau Sud
bosnord Sébastien vient de vous en
parler là bon ceux des beaux Snork sur
tout là je vous dirais que c'est là où
la machine c'est vraiment déployée là
par exemple le provençal le député
sortant de beaucena travaillait me
dit-on 13 14 heures par jour il y a 21
municipalités dans son comté il est allé
à tous les conseils de ville pour se
faire voir ils ont même engagé un
chauffeur pour le promener partout pour
qu'il puisse travailler en même temps
dans la voiture parce que son adversaire
principal général c'est un conservateur
Olivier Dumay qui est le maire de
Saint-Lambert donc déjà quand même assez
connu dans la région et beau Sud Samuel
Poulin ça a vraiment pas été facile
durant la pandémie je lui avais parlé il
avait été menacé à plusieurs reprises
dès qu'il allait à l'épicerie par
exemple il se faisait parler de la
gestion de la pandémie alors la campagne
a pas été facile pour ces deux-là
particulièrement si bien que la CAC a
envoyé beaucoup des députés du personnel
politique pour aller les voir leur
remonter le moral le carrément ils sont
un petit peu plus confiants pour chevaux
je dirais parce que la démographie dans
ce qu'on était là est différente si vous
avez le Lac Beauport un petit peu plus
haut lac de l'âge des gens qui sont plus
aisés
plus éduqués aussi ce côté-là est
reconnu pour avoir vraiment deux côtés
il a bien bien distinct et il pense
qu'ils vont être capable d'aller
chercher quand même une majorité
peut-être plus importante qui pense dans
Chauveau sinon on va surveiller Jean le
sache qui est très serré me dit-on entre
Québec solidaire et la coalition Québec
et François Legault déjà il est en mode
je pense que là même s'il dit on prend
rien pour acquis là il sait que demain
il va probablement revenir au Parlement
écouter bien ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
une campagne électorale qu'on le veuille
ou non surtout quand il y a 5 parties
c'est divisé
tout le monde essaye de se distinguer de
s'attaquer on est vu une coupe
m'attaquer 5 semaines je m'y attendais
mais on a beau s'y attendre
je suis resté de bonne humeur
[Rires]
très bien Véronique à tout de suite on
se reparle tout au long de la soirée et
puis on va à Montréal au Théâtre Corona
alexandre Duval bonsoir vous êtes avec
les libéraux Dominique anglaise
c'est qu'elle a elle a besoin que les
libéraux sortent pour aller voter
c'est vraiment le gros défi Patrice
parce que dans les deux dernières
semaines et demi de campagne à peu près
partout où on allait il y avait très peu
de militants libéraux et c'est pas une
exagération là il y en avait à peine
quelques dizaines à peu près partout où
on passait on l'a remarqué et à quelques
reprises on a questionné des libéraux
là-dessus on leur demandait ils sont où
les militants du parti ils sont où les
sympathisants et il y a quelques
tentatives d'explications qui nous ont
été données dans les derniers jours on
lui disait ben vous savez les libéraux
ils sont peut-être plus discrets moyen à
s'afficher publiquement ce qui était
évidemment pas le cas il y a plusieurs
années mais là c'est une des
explications qu'on nous a donnée sauf
que si les libéraux sont plus discrets
dans les rassemblements est-ce que c'est
parce que leurs sentiments
d'appartenance envers le Parti c'était
frité un petit peu est-ce que Madame
anglais dessus les convaincre durant
cette élection de rentrer au bercail de
continuer à soutenir le parti et c'est
le gros défi ce soir parce que Madame
Anglade elle le dit elle veut faire des
gains en dehors de l'île de Montréal
c'est une chose des châteaux forts à
protéger qui sont menacés qui vont être
serrés ce soir la soirée pour exterminer
très tard dans plusieurs
circonscriptions malgré ça madame
Anglade dit écoutez j'ai tout donné je
suis satisfait de la campagne que j'ai
menée de l'énergie que j'y ai mis
essentiellement pour elle les aider sont
jetés et sont électeurs de faire leur
choix ce soir
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir tout donné
dans cette campagne d'avoir mis toutes
les idées de la vente d'avoir été
d'avoir été à l'écoute aussi et d'avoir
été moi-même d'abord et avant tout
d'avoir été moi-même puis donc c'est
pour ça que je suis je vais avec ce
sentiment du devoir du devoir accompli
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup bonne soirée à tout de
suite alors campagne de Dominique
Anglade début laborieux je pense au dire
de tous mais elle Alec elle n'a pas
arrêté jusqu'à la fin non elle est pas
arrêtée puis le débat autour de
l'immigration les gardes de François
Legault lui ont donné de l'énergie à
dominer Anglade ça reste quand même là
c'est à côté des migration l'inclusivité
quelque chose avec lequel elle est à
l'aise pour laquelle d'ailleurs elle a
quitté la coalition Québec à l'époque
c'est vrai que ça lui donne un peu
d'énergie dans sa campagne parce que
l'organisation était déficient des
erreurs dans le cadre financier on
dirait que c'est sujet là lui ont donné
un petit peu de feu et elle a un bon
débat à Radio-Canada ce qui lui a aussi
donné une bonne fin de campagne est-ce
que ce sera suffisant pour sauver des
châteaux forts menacés on le verra ce
soir mais clairement pour dominer
qu'englade ça s'annonçait une campagne
difficile ça a été une campagne
difficile est-ce qu'on a été capable à
la fin de leur donner un petit soin à la
campagne c'est ce qu'on va voir ça
Chantal comme dit Alec plus monsieur
Legault parlait d'immigration puis on
avait l'impression madame anglaise
arrivait mieux à définir en fait
savoir au-delà de Madame Anglade qui se
définit sa définit ou ça donne une
raison d'aller voter à des électeurs
libéraux qui peut-être jusqu'à une
semaine du jour se disait ouf ça va pas
bien et puis on est pas très excité par
notre propre partie mais ça c'est une
profonde motivation on a en compte des
électeurs on en a vu en fin de semaine
qui ont apostrophy par exemple Gabriel
n'ado Dubois et est-ce que coller et ce
qui risque d'aider les libéraux ce soir
en tout cas à Montréal c'est pas qu'il
les immigrants s'en vont surtout à
Montréal c'est même pas qui parle pas
tous français c'est de se faire dire
qu'ils travaillent pas
ça quelqu'un qui se fait dire ça et j'en
ai rencontré c'est des gens qui sont
profondément heurter et qui vont s'en
aller voter à cause de ça et peut-être
qu'il serait pas allé il y a cinq ou six
jours et ça ça se traduit Sébastien dans
des circonscriptions très précises là
tout le nord de Montréal Verdun on a
parlé même ça Henri Sainte-Anne la
circonscription de la chef ça peut faire
en tout cas ça peut jouer ça peut bouger
l'aiguille voire même Laval parce que à
Laval la coalition Québec avait des
divisés sur Laval il a pas mené une
mauvaise campagne elle personnellement
elle a pas fait de gaffe Dominique
anglan mais c'est l'organisation qui
était qui était pas bonne autour d'elle
en fait partie laisser par Philippe
brouillard où il y avait plus de 8
militants nécessairement et pendant une
campagne interne en fait il faut
investir pendant quatre ans dans une vie
militante pour pouvoir arriver à la
finale lors de la campagne électorale et
avoir ses bras pour l'aider ça il avait
ça lui manquait cruellement dans cette
campagne état le 22 août on le vu le
lancement de cette campagne là
un peu d'absence on a l'impression
qu'elle était seule devant son bus de
campagne alors que les autres bon
François Legault c'était ses candidats
dans le nombre mais au moins il avait du
monde
sur cette campagne bah moi j'ai trouvé
très courageux elle conduit un véhicule
qui perd de l'huile depuis un bon moment
il y a plus de boussole et
heureusement pour elle monsieur le Gaule
beaucoup aidé dans la semaine et vous
savez cette idée que des nouveaux
arrivants sont insultés par les paroles
de Monsieur boulet et de monsieur
Legault j'en ai besoin entendu parler à
Québec supérieur le Québec c'est blanche
vidéo chrétien pour la français il y a
des gens qui ont été profondément
blessés c'est nous les chercher et pas
seulement des nouveaux arrivants on est
une zone des gens qui on a trouvé ça
inhumain quelque part on a trouvé ça
enfin ça on pense pas qu'en politique
aujourd'hui en 2022 ça puisse encore se
dire ça me fait ça on sent qu'on est
comme on entend des choses de la droite
en Europe c'est exactement ça vous la
droite One Piece
en région c'est tout un défi pour les
libéraux oui parce que même quand on
constate les trois circonscriptions de
l'amitié les candidats libéraux étaient
très en arrière et on n'a jamais vu ça
habituellement c'était se libéraux on se
dit en 2018 ne rend pas tes muscamin
mais on verra mais les candidats
libéraux portent tellement loin en
arrière je postures qu'en région ça va
avoir un impact à ce niveau-là il y a un
candidat un habitué qui était député
dans l'autre circonscription il y a un
bout de temps
exactement moi j'ai trouvé madame
Anglade est parti sans atout là le début
de la campagne aucun atout pas de
programme qui lui permet de se
distinguer plus de militants dans son
propre côté est en arrière il y avait je
disais tantôt d'enverde madame Mélenchon
était mesurée dans certains sondages à
des pilotes des cacahuètes et elle
un seul atout c'est de distinguer par sa
personnalité l'époque du gouvernement
Couillard c'était ça qu'elle devait
faire et ça ne fonctionnait pas elle
avait beau essayer ça ne fonctionnait
pas mais ça la mayonnaise a pris vers la
fin de la campagne on verra comment tout
ça va se concrétiser en nombre de sièges
avoir Valérie Gama je vous vous êtes au
m TELUS à Montréal avec Québec solidaire
qui a qui avait et qui a de grands
espoirs dans cette campagne
de grands espoirs en fait on veut on
s'est vraiment positionné dans les
derniers jours comme voulant être
peut-être l'opposition officielle on
veut ravir donc ce titre à Dominique
Anglade on allait faire d'ailleurs
campagne au cours des vraiment tout
dernier jour et même les dernières
heures dans les châteaux forts libéraux
on s'est promené beaucoup à Montréal
dans Maurice Richard dans Verdun dans
bio et donc ce sont vraiment ces
circonscriptions là qui sont ciblées et
qu'on espère donc ravirolibéraux ce soir
bon c'est même rendu jusqu'à old parce
que là-bas on sent certaines engouement
même si c'est une circonscription qui
est détenue depuis 1981 par les libéraux
donc une circonscription vraiment qui
qui est un château femme riche
Gaudreault d'ailleurs la député libéral
sortante a été élu là sans interruption
depuis 14 ans et c'est vraiment ces
circonscriptions là que l'on que l'on
cible et que l'on espère pouvoir avoir
pour former cette cette
opposition officielle et là je pense que
vous voyez des images du moment où
Gabriel la dose Dubois est allé s'est
rendu aux autres ce matin est allé
ça c'est très bien passé
j'ai fait mon choix pour la
circonscription de Gouin
ouais l'ambiance était plutôt bonne
aujourd'hui Patrice avec Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon qui a
l'impression d'avoir mené une bonne
campagne il était heureux au moment
d'aller voter il a fait remarquer que le
ciel était bleu peut-être voulait-il
dire bleu PQ quoi qu'il en soit vous
souviendrez sûrement le jour du
déclenchement de cette déclaration de
Paul Saint-Pierre flamandon qui avait
prédit que le Parti québécois serait
l'équipe Cendrillon du tournoi les
attentes étaient plutôt basses la traîne
dans les intentions de vote monsieur
Sinclair Plamondon était sans doute le
moins connu des chefs et il s'est révélé
d'une certaine façon dans les débats on
a constaté sur le terrain une vague de
sympathie envers lui les gens qui
venaient de féliciter le défi ce soir ce
sera de transformer cette sympathie en
vote sinon le carrosse de Cendrillon
pourrait bien se transformer en
citrouille donc on verra ce soir le taux
de participer sera déterminant
car aujourd'hui notamment dans un arrêt
dans son local électoral de sa
circonscription de Camille Laurin il
leur a dit bon vous pouvez être fier du
travail accompli mais ce n'est pas
terminé à cette heure-ci ils font encore
des appels pour mobiliser les électeurs
monsieur saint-pierre-flamondon a aussi
retrouvé sa famille dans son local
électoral de Camille Laurin aujourd'hui
qui n'a pas vu beaucoup depuis un mois
semblait vous savez il semblait fatigué
ces derniers jours on peut le comprendre
après 36 jours sur la route parfois les
émotions prennent le dessus vous allez
le constater dans cet extrait au chef du
PQ s'adresse à ces troupes
ça a été une campagne
très belle
aujourd'hui ce qui nous reste c'est de
d'aller vers les gens puis les inciter à
voter
oui après un marathon comme ça et déjà
Paul Saint-Pierre plat Mondon souvent
laisse aller sa sensibilité et dans des
entrevues ailleurs et il joue à livre
ouvert plus ça a été toute une campagne
pour tous les chefs notamment pour lui
merci beaucoup à tout de suite un tour
de table sur cette campagne du PQ parce
que évidemment
au début ça a pris quelques jours mais
l'analyse rapidement et les analyses et
les gens ont vu que il menait une
campagne différente en tout cas dans le
ton ça lui a profité oui il faudra voir
en effet si ça se transforme en succès
dans l'urne faut mettre les choses en
perspective par contre ils partaient de
tellement loin que chaque gain était
notable mais au moment où on se parle en
tout cas si on emploie les sondages le
Parti Québécois ne pas le même point
étage qu'il a eu aux élections de 2018
en 2018 c'était 17% pour 10 députés
est-ce que ce soir il va dépasser député
on serait jamais surpris il aura
probablement moins que 10 députés mais
il aura quand même réussi à sauver les
meubles pour sa campagne si le plus que
un ou deux députés comme on pensait au
début de la course vous êtes en deux
mots il y a fait une belle course mais
partait tellement loin car la ligne
d'arrivée est loin des autres j'entends
dans des circonstances plus normale pour
le Parti québécois dans son histoire on
s'en viendrait ne veiller funéraire avec
le genre de score qu'on a dans les
intentions de vote faut pas s'en faire
accroître l'autre problème et c'est à
vérifier c'est que traditionnellement et
en tout cas souvent le vote de
souverainiste dans les intentions de
vote par rapport à l'urne ça a été le
cas du Bloc québécois ça a été le cas du
PQ souvent et sur évaluer et combien de
fois est-ce qu'on se disait au bloc ou
au PQ on va atteindre ou franchir la
barre mythique du 50% et les sondages le
suggérer ça arrivait pas donc faudrait
pas que ce soit le cas ce soir parce
qu'on se retrouverait pas trop loin de
la case départ de la
ce qu'il voulait c'est d'abord sauver le
PQ parce qu'on sait pas dans quatre ans
on va en intro alors entre avoir un
député de député ou 10 12 députés ça
fait une grande différence pour la
partie québécois il va y avoir une
fatigue envers la coalition à venir
Québec à un moment donné les gens vont
chercher une alternative lui ce qu'il
devait garder s'ils sont partis en vie
je pense qu'il a réussi une campagne qui
lui permet de garder son parti en vie
mais dans quel ampleur on verra mais
pour pas le simple pas simple à Mondor
c'était l'objectif et il est atteint un
petit mot sur QS parce qu'on a vu québé
solidaire on parlait de l'immigration
des nouveaux arrivants il y a une
alternative au libéraux maintenant sur
l'île de Montréal qui est Québec
solidaire et au Québec solidaire on a
l'impression qu'on peut capitaliser
aussi sur les gaffes de François Legault
ce n'est pas uniquement les libéraux qui
peuvent en profiter mais que les
nouveaux arrivants qui ont pas le goût
de voter libéral pour être dans
certaines circonscriptions sortir en
masse voter pour US et donc par leur
permettre de faire des gains cette
dynamique là n'existait pas avant mais
Québec soldat est assez ouvert à
l'immigration comparativement à ce que
par exemple la correction de Québec ou
le Parti québécois propose
sur Québec solidaire le problème c'est
la marque de commerce libéral là on
parle des lecteurs qui ont voté pour
Justin Trudeau il y a un an et qui s'ils
veulent aller voter et dire je j'en ai
qu'on a dit la première réflexe ce
serait pas très tourner à Québec
solidaire ça va être de retourner vers
leur marque de commerce parce qu'on en
parle pas beaucoup mais même aujourd'hui
dans les intentions de vote fédérales
Justin Trudeau se porte beaucoup mieux
Montréal mais pas seulement Montréal que
le Parti libéral du Québec donc il y a
un électorat là qui a voté libéral est
encore contente du Parti libéral fédéral
que réflexe naturelle ça favoriserait
plus les libéraux que QS qui a pas
vraiment encore travailler
c'est c'est communauté là de la façon
dont ils ont besoin évidemment si on
attend la platoïdisation du Québec au
complet pour que US s'en servait
d'entre nous pour couvrir
vous vous voyez un jour vous une fusion
un accord non ça me semblait possible
impossible ça me semble impossible on se
rappelle que amircadir avait ça avait
tenté puis Hélène David aussi mais ça
avait pas fonctionné les membres
voulaient rien savoir mais rien et
considérait même le PQ comme un ennemi
plus intense que les autres parties le
parti à abattre le parti abattre parce
que le parti de l'identité nationaliste
d'une part mais d'autre part le
nationalisme
identitaire mais d'autre part aussi la
marche à gravir pour devenir un vrai
parti il fallait éliminer le PQ pour
aller chercher ses votes là qui est un
vote un peu progressiste et là ce qui se
passe c'est que la montée de Plamondon
pourrait on ne sait pas encore on va
savoir ce soir mais ça se peut qu'il
soit à la tête d'une troupe de 2
et ça ce qui les gains qu'il a fait je
regarde des gains sont important dans
certains compter selon les sondages des
sondages et ça pourrait retirer des
votes ou AQs je regarde dans Maurice
Richard là le Parti québécois dernier
sondage doit selon Québec 125 sera monté
à 20% ce qui était pas du tout là il y a
quelques temps et c'est à quoi comme
résultat ça arrive comme résultat que
Haroun Boisy et Audrey sont face à face
donc Québec soldat et la carte sont face
à face à base de terminer ce soir donc
le Québec le PQ nuit à Québec solidaire
dans certains comtés c'est clair bon
parce qu'à terme cinq parties on a
beaucoup souligné à cinq parties
monsieur Legault regarde ça l'opposition
est divisé et c'est une voix Pavil
parfait une campagne électorale
l'environnement d'une campagne M ça va
avoir un bouledog et ils l'ont trouvé
mais il y a pris six sept points alors
je pense qu'il faut regarder aussi des
choses froidement une victoire morale à
11h ce soir ça voudra pas grand chose et
l'histoire vous lui rapidement je répète
depuis 42 ans en 2018 le PQ a connu le
pire le pire résultat de son histoire 17
% et du siège et ce soir on se demande
si votre capable de faire aussi bien que
le pire résultat moi personnellement ne
me demandez pas de croire qu'on va avoir
l'un de victoire quelconque c'est soit
demain je pense mais est-ce que ça
pourrait pas jouer dans certains comtés
comme Jonquières dans l'Est du Québec
les Îles de la Madeleine puis
dépendamment du vote
à la boule de cristal mais j'aime y
penser un peu mais dans certains côtés
peut-être que ça pourrait peut-être
faire un petit peu la différence dans ce
contrat très bien quelqu'un qui a fait
la différence ne serait-ce que dans la
dynamique de cette campagne électorale
c'est le parti conservateur Jacques
Audrey Charbonneau le parti conservin
qui était à deux qui était même pas à
deux en fait qui était à 1,7 pour cent
la dernière fois tous les sondages le
donnent entre 10 et 14 on verra ce soir
vous êtes au lac de l'âge d'un chevaux
bien sûr ce soir
oui exactement c'est ici qu'aura lieu la
soirée électorale pour le Parti
conservateur Éric Zem vient tout juste
d'arriver avec son conjoint justement
son ami est conseillé Martin dusautel
ils vont donc passer la soirée dans une
dans une suite ici rejoindre leur
partisans militant un peu plus tard vers
20h 20h30 on attend selon le parti entre
500 et 600 personnes des candidats des
bénévoles également
Eric diamant aujourd'hui est allé voter
justement avec son conjoint il s'est dit
confiant et il est vraiment persuadé que
le Parti conservateur va causer la
surprise aujourd'hui parce que justement
comme vous mentionniez on n'a pas de
points de comparaison pour le Parti
conservateur il a l'impression que les
conservateurs sont discrets et qu'il
pourrait causer la surprise dans
plusieurs circonscriptions il est donné
deuxième dans plusieurs circonscriptions
derrière la CAQ et donc selon lui c'est
un bon signe et il le dit aussi dans les
derniers jours qu'il préparait déjà
l'élection de 2026
notre profil d'électeur est un profil
qui normalement traditionnellement votre
moins et mais cette fois-ci les motiver
donc est-ce que ça peut changer quelque
chose moi je pense que c'est pas le fait
que par exemple le bureau de vote par
anticipation ont connu plus de succès
cette année je pense que c'est pas
étranger à notre montée le fait que
c'est dans la région de Québec une chose
qui est sûr c'est sûr que tu en as
peut-être pas le même stress que les
autres partis parce qu'on est la seule
formation politique aujourd'hui qui est
certaine de faire mieux que la dernière
fois ça je pense que personne qui peut
contester ça de notre part
effectivement il a tout à fait raison
avec 1,6 il va être il va multiplier par
8 au moins le score de la dernière fois
et vous avez raison il le dit depuis
quelques jours écoutez attendez-vous pas
des miracles déjà où on est c'est un
miracle en soi
voilà très bien merci beaucoup Jacques
Audrey à tout de suite un petit tour
avec Olivier Bachant vous êtes à Laval
dans un bureau de vote il y a eu un
incident
ou exactement Patrice on se trouve un
présentement à l'école Simon Vanier
c'est dans Laval des rapides et ici il y
a au moins une quinzaine de personnes
qui sont repartis sans voter nous a dit
le personnel d'élection donc ces gens-là
sont répartisés parce que leur nom ne
figure pas sur la liste électorale moi
j'ai été témoin j'ai vu trois personnes
repartir qui sont dans cette situation
là ce qu'une dame nous a expliqué c'est
qu'elle a déménagé depuis la dernière
élection qu'elle a amené toutes les
preuves montrant quelle est sa nouvelle
adresse quel est son ancienne adresse et
malgré tout on la trouve nulle part sur
la liste électorale du Québec c'est
comme si elle n'existait pas alors elle
a insisté pendant plusieurs minutes pour
pouvoir voter et finalement elle est
repartie sans pouvoir exercer un son
devoir démocratique alors on a aucune
idée de l'ampleur de la situation
combien de gens au total n'ont pas pu
exercer leur droit de vote ici à ce
bureau de vote aujourd'hui on a demandé
des précisions élections Québec par
courriel on aura sans doute des
explications un petit peu plus tard dans
la soirée alors on se trouve à Laval des
rapides parce que c'est une
circonscription qui sera à surveiller ce
soir en fait toute l'île de Laval sera
surveillée ici en 2018 les libéraux
avaient remporté 5 des 6
circonscriptions la CAQ était parvenue à
remporter la circonscription de
Sainte-Rose mais le portrait pourrait
changer ce soir alors dans la valve des
rapides c'est ça le Polo qui se présente
qui se représente pour les libéraux le
seul député libéral sortant à se
présenter pour le Parti libéral du
Québec il va affronter la cachiste
Céline et tayyane et c'était très serré
Patrice lors des dernières élections en
2018 il avait emporté par moins de 300
voix alors ce soir ce sera une bataille
qui sera évidemment à surveiller même
scénario je vous dirai d'environ c'est
la libérale Annabella Monteiro qui va
affronter valerichem smalt de la CAQ et
lors des dernières élections le député
libéral sortant genre Roussel avait
emporté par moins de 600 voix alors
est-ce que les libéraux vont réussir à
conserver ces circonscriptions si le
vote francophone s'effondre pour les
libéraux ça pourrait basculer dans le
giron de la CAPAC en fait qui peut-être
remporté cinq des six circonscriptions
on pense que sommet des pourrait rester
dans le giron libéral c'est
conscriptions où il y a davantage de
votre anglophone et allophone si les
libéraux perdent cheminées ça va être
une très très très très mauvaise soirée
pour les libéraux mais les ondes les
autres compter de Laval vous le disiez
Sébastien c'est intéressant parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de compter en jeu et c'est
5 sur 6 c'est beaucoup et voici à quoi
ressemble la balle et six
circonscriptions il y en a une
actuellement qui est appartient à la
coalition à venir Québec c'est
Christopher skate qui avait été élu dans
cette circonscription pour la carte en
2018 mais toutes les autres à part show
Médée ici sont dans la mire de sont une
cible de la coalition Québec est-ce que
les
déclarations sur l'immigration vont
jouer un rôle ce soir dans la
mobilisation peut-être d'un certain vote
à Laval faudra voir cheminée en passant
c'est pas Guy Wallet qui se présente
dans la circonscription de cheminée
c'est Guy Wallet qui avait été élu sur
le parti idéal dans ma carte et il est
devenu grise parce qu'il y a pas de
résultats qui sont encore rentrés mais
ça me permet de vous présenter les
candidats dans cette circonscription
madame la cueillan Olivier qui se
présente pour le Parti libéral mais
monsieur planète
pour la coalition Québec pouvoir
réverser cette ne devrait pas pouvoir
averse cette circonscription si il y en
a une qui rester rouge à Laval c'est
bien l'assurance de chomede les autres
sont dans la merde de la clinique ouais
et ça fait mal pour les potentiellement
ça va faire mal pour les libéraux là-bas
elle est partie libéral recrutait
beaucoup d'anciens conseillers
municipaux pour porter leur couleur
pendant cette campagne électorale ci
dans Laval en se disant ils viennent
avec une connaissance du terrain ils
viennent avec une machine politique on a
peut-être pu la machine qu'on avait mais
gardien chercher les conseillers
municipaux qui sont implantés depuis
longtemps viennent avec des bénévoles
viennent avec une connaissance du
terrain ont chacun leurs organisateurs
locaux on espère pouvoir si on est à
l'arraché dans ce circonscription là
pour voir aller faire une différence
avec la machine qu'on a recruté à Laval
faudra voir ça va être suffisant
facile le Parti libéral en est à se
recruter des machines municipales à
Laval qu'est-ce qui lui reste une fois
qu'on franchit l'île Jésus et puis l'île
de Montréal parce que on n'est pas en
train de parler de région éloignée ou
une partie libéral peut-être pas de
racine je dois m'aider c'est en passant
c'est l'ancienne circonscription de
Thomas marker dans son incarnation
libérale
c'est une région les libéraux étaient
avantagée
d'huile dans qui
c'est oui juste la bombe parlait de
plancher historique pour le PQ le
plancher historique
ils seront pas loin de leur plancher
historique parce que sinon faut remonter
au 19e siècle pour les libéraux mais
c'est ça qui est en jeu ce soir aussi
pour les libéraux et puis ici c'est le
cas ça veut dire qu'on a une
renouvellement quasi complet du profil
de électoral du Québec et si le plancher
les deux parties traditionnelles qui se
sont affrontés pendant des décennies
depuis des libéraux si atteignent leur
plancher ça veut dire que le portrait
complètement changé alors il y a comme
une transformation assez dramatique ils
atteignent leur plancher mais ne veulent
pas puis c'est normal on les comprend
ils veulent pas mourir alors le jeu
politique reste à 5 on parlait de
transformation tout à l'heure il faut
revoir dans quelle mesure puis vous
disiez lu jamais au grand jamais il y
aura de fusion EQs c'est à dire que QS
le PQ reste ça veut dire que les
conservateurs
ne mourront pas compte tenu du vote à la
fin les libéraux encore oui oui mais les
libéraux pourrait être aussi faible
soit-il dans cette élection-là pour être
l'alternative à la casse si jamais la
carte tombe en
disgrâce parce que les différences sont
pas si grande que ça c'est-à-dire oui
sur sur l'immigration sur la langue mais
mais ça s'arrange je veux dire le reste
là un parti qui vise à représenter la
classe moyenne qui se présente comme
locomotive économique du Québec
supposons que la casse la carte fasse
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs par ailleurs
la carte
avec 38% des votes c'est le parti qui
prendrait le pouvoir avec le plus faible
pourcentage de vote de l'histoire du
Québec pour un parti majoritaire comme
la dernière fois puis à 5 parties ça va
être ça encore juste pour vous montrer
le défi de du Parti libéral ça c'est le
Laval l'île de Montréal
à monter ici ils ont deux
circonscriptions lapinière à la porte
mais au-delà de ça il y a seulement deux
autres circonscriptions au Québec c'est
dans l'Utah ouais à part ça les libéraux
ne sont plus là c'est du Bleu Poudre de
la collection Québec dans les
Laurentides dans la naudière ont monté
régie en esprit aussi à part évidemment
les petits points ici c'est Québec
solidaire dans Sherbrooke donc c'est
tout un défi mais je précise quand même
à 17% 18% du vote ce soir le Parti
libéral reste la position officielle
quand même parce que son 17 18%, mais la
marche mais la marché haute mais sur 17
18% et plus payant qu'un 16 17 % pour
les autres parties
la carte qu'on voit là du parti libérale
du Québec c'était la carte du parti
libéral fédérale avant 2015 il restait
rien à l'extérieur ou presque pas des
miettes et tout le monde disait un
changement de paradigme
ont toujours se manger les conservateurs
sont assurés de devenir de nouveaux
parties naturelles du gouvernement au
Canada qu'est-ce qui est arrivé la
marque de commerce libéral est beaucoup
plus forte que la performance du parti
ce soir ou du Parti libéral fédéral en
2011 quand il est tombé en troisième
classe et on l'a vu encore et encore je
vous dis pas que c'est le cas partout au
Canada mais certainement au Québec ce
parti-là a une marque de commerce qui a
des chances de revivre plus facilement
que que d'autres et les parties revivent
demander à Jean Charrat québécois
est au centre de l'échiquier politique
au Québec c'est vrai au Canada aussi les
parties comme la coalition de Québec le
Parti libéral du Québec les ratissent
très très large ils ont des chefs ils
ont des passes où ça va moins bien mais
en gros il ratissent un énorme électorat
que des parties qui sont à plus à droite
plus à gauche de la difficulté récolter
donc la renaissance du parti libérale
elle est possible puis peut-être que le
problème qu'on a aussi on verra le taux
de participation parce que moi je pense
que ça c'est une clientèle qui aura pas
voté alors quand on voit des élections
provinciales au Québec puis tu as pas 70
%, 75 % du monde qui vont voter ça veut
dire qu'il y a des gens qui restent chez
eux et la clientèle libérale pour être
de celle-là c'est intéressant parce
qu'elle pourrait là nous vous êtes à
Québec dans tâchereau Taschereau c'était
bien sûr une circonscription mythique
parce que Catherine Dorion était là
est-ce que il pourrait avoir des
changements on verra mais ça a voté en
tout cas très fort chez vous
oui c'est à votre fort dans la capitale
nationale si on regarde les cinq
circonscriptions ou les électeurs ont le
plus voté jusqu'à maintenant quatre
d'entre elles c'est justement dans la
région de la Capitale nationale avec
Louis Hébert en tête à 62% ensuite de ça
il y a Montarville à 58 % ici on se
trouve dans ta chevaux le taux de vote
aussi est élevé le loto de participation
est au tour de 54% Catherine Dorion
n'est plus là mais c'est Étienne
Grandmont pour Québec solidaire qui
essaie de conserver la circonscription
on est au cœur de la ville de Québec au
centre-ville si on regarde un petit peu
plus au nord dans Jean Lesage seul
Zanetti aussi pour Québec solidaire et
cette conserver la circonscription
encore une fois orange mais sinon
partout dans la capitale nationale qu'on
va qu'on aille dans Port Neuf jusque
dans Charlevoix et au sud de Québec dans
chaudière à Palace tout le reste c'est
coalition à venir Québec c'est bleu
pâles est-ce que les conservateurs vont
réussir une percée en gros la question
ce soir pour la capitale nationale c'est
est-ce que la carte va changer
après les élections alors c'est la
grande question on verra
très bien merci beaucoup vous êtes là
toute la soirée avec nous à Québec on
s'en va tout de suite à Saint-Georges de
Beauce Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc dans la
circonscription de beau-sud donc c'est
là et peut-être même plus qu'à chevaux
on verra mais c'est là qu'on
conservateur pourrait être élu chez vous
deux conservateurs
en direct ce soir effectivement de
Saint-Georges devant un bureau de
scrutin parce que les luttes ici vont
être extrêmement intéressantes je
commence par Bose sud on a beaucoup fait
la blague il va falloir rester vigilant
pour voter pour le bon poulain parce que
des poulets il y en a trois Patrice il y
a des blagues Samuel le député sortant
oh oui absolument donc Samuel poulain de
la CAQ il y a Antoine poulain également
du Parti libéral mais lui il a été
parachuté il travaillait dans le bureau
de circonscription Dominique Anglade à
Montréal et aussi parachuté ici et il y
a Jonathan Poulin ce jeune avocat de 30
ans qui se présente pour le Parti
conservateur du Québec d'ailleurs nous
plus tard on va se rendre à la
Guadeloupe à son rassemblement pour voir
comment ça se passe et Jonathan Poulin
Patrice oui Jonathan poulet Patrice pour
votre information vous savez il a ben
c'est parti conservateur ils ont apporté
cette tradition de
installer des pancartes en avant des
maisons là-bas lui là il y en a marqué
il en a écoulé 1100 il dit je parlais un
de ces organisateurs tantôt il dit on
n'a pas été capable d'en avoir assez
mais finalement ça ça a bien été cette
stratégie là beau ce Nord on va suivre
ça également parce que là il y a le
maire très populaire maire de
Saint-Lambert de Lozon qui se présente
contre le provençal de la CAQ encore là
ça va être ça risque d'être très très
serré deux enjeux en bosse Patrick
d'abord Patrice d'abord il y a le fait
que les entreprises manquent de
travailleurs et si le taux de chômage
est à 1,6% la base c'est le royaume des
PME il a il y en a 500 des entreprises
dans le secteur manufacturier et neuf 9
sur 10 manque de travailleurs alors
pendant la campagne électorale il y a
beaucoup été question ici d'immigration
et il y a aussi la façon dont la
pandémie s'est déroulée il y a un fond
de conservatisme
vous le savez le ministre de la Santé
sortant Christian Dubé qui était
débarqué en bourse qui avait dit que les
beaux seront avaient des têtes durs
parce qu'il refusait de se faire
vacciner ça a été les puissante aussi de
la pandémie
très bien merci beaucoup on va vous
suivre ce soir c'est fascinant la base
dans l'histoire politique du Québec la
base Fabien Roy quand 76 se fait lire
avec son parti rassemblement national
il y a quelque chose en Bose de très
particulier bon évidemment au fédéral
Maxime Bernier compagnie mais ils sont
très entrepreneurs aussi en même temps
les libéraux avaient des racines-là
d'utile donc c'est un quand on entend
que les libéraux ont parachuté quelqu'un
du de la séquence de du bureau Dominique
Anglade il y a eu les ministres
libéraux longtemps ça montre à quel
point le parti est en difficulté
Sébastien sur la carte pour l'instant
c'est clair résultat 2018 donc vous
voyez la nette domination de la
coalition à venir Québec bossenal c'est
ici Saint-Georges de Beauce notamment
bossud c'est beau-nord pardon c'est ici
Saint-Georges de beau
le Parti conservateur a un fantasme en
chaudière à Palace je me permettait
l'expression ce serait d'aller chercher
belle chasse ici à côté s'ils vont
chercher beau snor bossud ils pensent
pouvoir aller chercher Bellechasse aussi
et juste un mot sur la circonscription
d'Éric duem est-ce que peut-être qu'il
regrette monsieur Diem de pas cette
présenter dans Bose Nord ou dans vos Sud
parce qu'il aurait peut-être eu des
meilleures chances de se faire élire
mais dans cette circonscription à lui
Éric dum Chauveau c'est une
circonscription particulière dans ce
coin ici
avec Beauport très riche Patrick Roy
avait sa maison là au Lac Beauport il a
déménagé depuis alors que plus bas ici
le Red villes peut-être plus classe
moyenne donc ce sera intéressant de voir
comment les gens de cette
circonscription qui s'étend quand même
assez loin au nord le stonam et ainsi de
suite votre rapport ou contre Monsieur
duem ce soir c'est un peu comme il y a
plusieurs circonscriptions comme ça mais
Verdun c'est le même phénomène l'île des
sœurs d'un côté puis Verdun Verdun de
l'autre quartier différent qui peut
voter différemment très très différent
Émilie Nicolas que vous connaissez que
l'on voit notre panel du four sont avec
nous ils vont venir comme ça au courant
de la soirée Émilie Christian bonsoir
bonsoir alors premier commentaire je
vous laisse le choix vous êtes
libre improvisation libre sur le thème
de la campagne qu'est-ce qui vous a
frappé sur le thème du qu'on est en
train de redessiner la carte électorale
du Québec qu'en pensez-vous Christian
c'est clairement une élection de
transition moi je dirais que ma première
impression c'est que je serai fier
d'être Québécois puis de vivre dans une
grande démocratie je pense qu'il faut le
dire puis quand même l'élément qu'on
sait nouveau là c'est que le taux de
participation semble vraiment plus
important que la dernière fois que c'est
ce que le sentant le directeur général
des élections et ça c'est important moi
au départ ce que je surveillais à la
suite du coup de massue des données de
Statistiques Canada juste quelques jours
avant la campagne sur la chute accélérée
du français à Montréal à Laval je vous
ai ce qu'on va parler du français et de
l'immigration sur cette campagne là la
deuxième chose que je surveillaise c'est
le phénomène iridum tel élément nouveau
voilà campagne qu'est-ce que ça allait
donner ou est-ce que ça va aboutir et en
fait la deuxième chose au début que je
regardais est-ce que Québec solidaire va
continuer sa montée parce qu'on sait
Quebec solidaire aspirait aspire encore
on n'a pas des résultats à devenir
vraiment comme l'opposition officielle
au gouvernement logo je te dis la
campagne s'est déroulée ces choses-là
ont évoluées ça a été intéressant mais
moi c'était ça mon premier pas Émilie
mais c'est sûr que quand on regarde la
carte électorale comme on le fait tout à
l'heure ce qui est ce qui est frappant
c'est les corps entre les centres
urbains bien sûr Montréal mais aussi le
sang de la ville de Québec Sherbrooke et
puis le reste le reste de la carte
électorale actuellement avant avant la
coalition à venir Québec lorsque les
gouvernements formaient le pouvoir
surtout majoritaire il y avait au moins
une bonne représentation sur l'île de
Montréal pour avoir leur chemin vers la
majorité depuis la coalition à venir
Québec c'est plus le cas et je pense que
ça a une influence sur les thèmes qui
sont ressortis durant la campagne
électorale et la façon dont on en a
parlé donc l'histoire des des villes des
rois des champs est très et très visible
sur la carte électorale peut-être plus
que plus que en fait depuis très
longtemps dans l'histoire du Québec et
puis j'ai hâte de voir si la carte va
percer à Montréal si on fait une bonne
campagne ou si on va arriver avec à la
fin de la soirée avec une avec une carte
encore plus divisée entre les villes et
les régions essentiellement à la fin de
la soirée lesquels sont les conséquences
sociales et politiques que ça va avoir
pour le Québec aussi ouais parce que
c'est plus accentué Christian le
Montréal d'un côté le reste du Québec de
l'autre ça a toujours été comme ça à
l'époque de Duplessis c'était ça ça fait
des décennies que c'est comme ça donc ça
va être intéressant de voir c'est une
élections de transition puis tout le
monde connaît pour acquis en fait là qui
avait 5 parties un parti tropical PQ
c'est fini c'est un peu ça que les gens
pensaient il y a pas si longtemps là il
semble que le PQ c'est pas fini donc on
va se retrouver encore avec cinq parties
comme vous l'avez dit notre mode de
scrutin fonctionne assez bien avec
quelle partie Ottawa ça fait des
décennies en fait que quatre parties ça
marche bien avec cinq parties c'est
moins sûr et c'est clair qu'après
l'élection on sait pas encore mais il
faut se poser le problème des deux
grandes parties francophones de gauche
le PQ est Québec solidaire tout à
l'heure a rappelé à quel point qu'avec
soldat voulait rien savoir en fait d'une
alliance d'une fusée avec le PQ mais le
problème va se poser parce que sinon
solidaire qui a frappé quand même un
nœud idéologique durant cette campagnol
avec leurs famoustache taxe orange on a
réalisé qui est un peu trop idéologique
mais il voulait à tout prix trouver des
super riches au Québec où il y en avait
pas si les gens de Québec solidaires
aspire au pouvoir il y aura pas d'autres
choix que de penser à s'allier un peu PQ
parce que notre mode de scrutin qui est
adaptée
ça va nous amener au sujet du la réforme
du mode de scrutin
inévitablement les gens vont parler de
ça et nous en tout cas on va en parler
ce soir est-ce que c'est l'usage que
c'est vraiment une petite clique juste
des intellectuels est-ce que le gens
veulent ça Émilie Christian vous êtes
avec nous je voulais le souligner vous
vous serez là tout au long de la soirée
merci au revoir merci et ce que je veux
souligner mesdames et messieurs c'est
que on se rapproche des résultats on
s'en va aux yeux de la Madeleine il est
19h et dépoussière les bureaux là-bas
sont fermés ou les madeleineaux donc ont
voté votre bureau sont fermés c'est une
heure plus tard là-bas donc je joins
tout de suite Isabelle Larose bonsoir
Isabelle
bonsoir vous avez vous une lutte là je
vais utiliser l'expression du candidat
libéral c'est une lutte de coq là chez
vous avec Jonathan Lapierre et Joël
Arsenault député sortant Jonathan
Lapierre qui est mère
exactement je vous attends la pierre qui
était mère des Îles de la Madeleine
depuis 2013 je dois la recevoir
qui lui aussi a été maire des Îles de la
Madeleine en fait c'est Jonathan
Lapierre qui l'a délogé de la mairie en
2013 et là cette année les deux hommes
recroisent le faire sur la scène
provinciale deux hommes qui n'ont pas
toujours la même vision des choses on a
effectivement vu une certaine animosité
entre les deux personnages c'est Gilles
Thériault le candidat libéral qui a
parlé d'un combat de coq lors du débat
local ici donc j'ai le terrarium aussi
qui est bien connu le libéral ici dans
le milieu des arts chasse aux phoques la
pêche qui va être solidaire non plus qui
est pas en reste avec un ancien
conseiller municipal qui est très engagé
dans le secteur agroalimentaire donc ça
sera très intéressant de voir tout ça
surtout à une semaine après le passage
de la tempête Fiona qui a fait beaucoup
de dommages ici aux îles et quand on a
rencontré des électeurs un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui il nous disait que l'enjeu
des changements climatiques de
l'environnement c'est devenu un thème
central pour eux et que ça avait pesé
dans la balance lorsqu'ils se sont
présentés aux urnes non plus en écouter
deux d'entre eux
la tempête le changement climatique
sénégalais on est dans le siège les
premières classes si on peut dire que
ouais c'est important pour moi pour mes
enfants que je pense voter un peu en ce
sens là
l'environnement avec l'ouragan qu'on
vient d'avoir ça nous rattrape un peu là
je pense que ça va être important pour
les pour les pour nos enfants puis nos
petits enfants qui peut-être eux vont le
trouver plus dur que nous
intéressant merci beaucoup Isabelle à
plus tard aux îles
on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé tout au
long de l'été de la fonderie tout au
long de l'automne de cette campagne
électorale monsieur Legault est allé
chez vous Jean-Marc bonsoir c'est une
campagne qui était tout sauf ennuyant en
tout cas
effectivement il faut dire en fait que
ce qui a ajouté à tout ça c'est que les
deux principaux adversaires en fait on a
ratat et médicaments donc la député
sortante site Québec solidaire émise
laissartérin et Daniel Bernard de la
coalition à venir Québec leurs candidat
ancien député aussi du Parti libéral ici
ne semblait pas s'apprécier beaucoup
faut le dire on le voyait dans les
débats qui avaient lieu ici il y a même
une plainte officielle déposée directeur
général des élections de la part de
Québec solidaire on reprochait aux
candidats de la CAQ de cette présentée
au vote par anticipation d'avoir serré
des mains donc on le sentait vraiment
dans le ton et vous l'avez dit quand
François Legault s'est présenté ici dans
les derniers jours de la campagne
électorale ça a vraiment fait en sorte
de raviver ce débat ce duel en T2
candidats mais aussi en même temps entre
des idées qui s'opposent en lien avec la
fonderie orne c'est ça dont on a
beaucoup parlé pendant la campagne
électorale cette entreprise qui peut
émettre davantage d'arsenic donc jusqu'à
100 nanogrammes dans l'air alors que la
norme C3 on a Québec solidaire d'un côté
donc avec la députée actuelle qui a
beaucoup militaire pour que cette norme
c'est quoi soit respecté et d'un autre
côté on a la CAQ qui est allé d'un juste
milieu si on veut en fait on a dit à
l'entreprise vous pouvez émettre jusqu'à
15 donc 5 fois la norme mais on veut que
vous baissiez davantage pour une
question de santé au niveau de la
population parce qu'il était démontré
qu'il y avait des quatre cancers du
poumon notamment donc c'est devenu en
quelque sorte ça un enjeu électoral en
fait c'est le principal enjeu à Rouen
Noranda mais il faut pas oublier aussi
les gens du thé médicament évidemment
mais c'est clair maintenant restez à
avoir est-ce que ça aura un impact sur
le taux de participation aussi ici tout
à fait monsieur LEGO a dit ça sera aux
gens de décider on verra donc mais c'est
effectivement merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
c'est effectivement quelque chose que le
candidat de la CAQ Manon je me tourne
vers vous soit l'ancien député libéral
parce qu'à Rouen les gens qui sont loin
de ça
comme je suis les gens de Montréal
votaient ça serait certainement le pas
le même résultat que les gens de Rouen
c'est pas clair que tout le monde veut
que ça ferme
mais c'est pas juste ça c'est que tout à
fait mais sauf que dans le fond la
fonderie on a déjà voir d'abord été une
mine et puis cent ans donc eu des
impacts depuis 20 ans c'est une fonderie
où on fait beaucoup d'impact sur
l'environnement mais on peut pas régler
ça en criant ciseau et moi ce que je
trouve dommage c'est comment le dossier
est devenu viscéral et polarisé et c'est
pas c'est pas des choses qui peuvent se
décider ou se réveiller rapidement créer
un ciseau il faut avoir un certain
rationnel mais je pense que moi peu
importe le résultat ce soir la fonderie
devra faire des ajustements mais il
faudra donner du temps mais il y aura
quelque chose à adresser vous êtes fait
40 ans là on peut pas en deux ans ou en
une année arrivé à trois ou même à 15
nanogrammes scientifique je peux pas
vous dire si c'est ça mais moi ce que je
ça fait au-dessus de 20 ans que ça se
passe et dans les dernières années c'est
devenu un enjeu à ou un oranda mais
écoutez les gens vivent à côté de la
fonderie depuis il y a des gens qui sont
nés et deuxième troisième génération à
côté de la fonderie alors mais moi je
dis oui faut que ça serait oui il faut
tendre améliorer le score mais il faut
avoir un certain rationnel et lorsqu'on
constate quand c'est une campagne
électorale mais c'est pas l'arrivée et
je pose sur qu'on a les meilleurs
suggestions et tout le monde des semble
découvrir ça la classe politique alors
que ça fait 45 ans qu'on connaît qu'on
sait qu'il y a des rapports il y a un
peu peut-être d'hypocrisie collective
là-dedans là écoutez c'est une
raffinerie c'était tout de même avant
maintenant on importe les métaux de
l'extérieur et de très loin et on
raffine là c'est pas nouveau moi je suis
étonné que c'est le lac à Sisco là-bas
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait qu'il y a
pas un poisson peut faire 10 minutes
ça va mieux là
c'est pas nouveau mais comme ça elle
avait une campagne électorale grand je
dirais à la députée de Québec solidaire
il faut le dire oui grâce c'est rare que
je souligne ça mais on n'a pas besoin
nécessairement de s'excuser auprès des
journalistes pour ce qui est arrivé dans
le bureau de vote de coing mais la
fonderie journalistique énorme que qui a
été fait également bon rapidement sur la
fonderie là je dis que c'est la dernière
fonderie au Canada en terme de de
stratégie nationale on parle de garder
nos entreprises ici notre pote avoir
l'exportation d'avoir tout à l'étranger
ça fait partie du débat mais c'est aussi
au gouvernement de trouver une manière
que les gens qui vivent près de la
fonderie est une santé qui soit
acceptable on est plus entendre plus si
on a créé par exemple à l'abbaye pour le
glissement de terrain programme pour
acheter les maisons permettre aux gens
de déménager ce qu'on peut imaginer
quelque chose pour loin on est rendu là
oui la fonderie est importante mais un
moment donné on est plus non plus dans
des normes des années 60
après la campagne électorale faudrait
que les gouvernements locaux et
provinciaux s'y attelle parce que ça va
rester un débat important vous êtes en
épuis dans le temps de Germinal non
évoluer très bien on s'en va moi vous me
parliez de Laval chouchou pour moi j'en
ai plusieurs en fait j'ai Sherbrooke
Saint-François côté j'ai hâte vraiment
d'avoir les premiers résultats dans
Sherbrooke et de Saint-François Brigitte
bonsoir Saint-François
qui est-ce qui a lancé sa campagne là
dans un vignoble c'est très beau le 22
août le dernier ils espèrent faire un
gain là avec l'ancienne directrice de la
santé publique une médecin Sherbrooke
une grosse bataille également ça va être
très intéressant chez vous
ouais mon petit doigt me dit ce soir que
vous allez avoir le regard tourné vers
Sherbrooke assez souvent vous l'avez dit
du côté de Saint François c'est une
lutte qui est serrée vous avez là la CAQ
avec Geneviève Weber qui est la député
sortante qui a été élu en 2018 et là le
Québec solder qui est arrivé avec une
candidate d'une personnalité publique
très connue ici très impliqué dans la
région docteur Mélissa généreux qui on
le sait s'est impliqué au moment de la
tragédie de lac-mégantique qui a été
impliquée au moment de la pandémie
également directrice de la santé
publique en Estrie donc évidemment ce
sera une lutte très serrée du côté de
Saint-François et quand on regarde du
côté de Sherbrooke ici c'est Christine
Labrit de Québec solder qui est la
député sortante et là ben François
Legault a misé sur Caroline
Saint-Hilaire pour tenter de ravir le
siège Caroline Saint-Hilaire ancienne
mairesse donc de Longueuil pendant 8 ans
elle a déjà été député blociste
également du côté de la Chambre des
communes donc Caroline Saint-Hilaire les
spécialistes disaient en début de
campagne oui elle est connue pour
François Legault est-elle connue des
sherbroquois belle la réponse est dans
l'urne dans les urnes on le saura un peu
plus tard à savoir ce Caroline
Saint-Hilaire pour la carte a réussi
vraiment à se faire connaître des chers
bocaux sur le terrain Christine
l'abrielle qui a toujours dit pendant
qu'elle faisait campagne et lorsqu'elle
a été élue en 2018 rappelez-vous ça a
été une surprise elle qui a défait donc
Luc Fortin en 2018 du parti libérale
elle a dit je sens que je suis un
caillou pour la CAQ ici à Sherbrooke
parce qu'il y a juste Christine Labrit
ici pour Québec solidaire tout autour ce
sont des députés de la CAQ qui avait été
en 2018 donc effectivement lutte très
serré chez nous autant du côté de
Saint-François que du côté de Sherbrooke
et je vous dirais que tout au long de
cette campagne on a beaucoup beaucoup
parlé de la santé parce que bon on a des
résidences privées pour un nez qui ont
fermé il y a des médecins de l'urgence
qui sont sortis pour réclamer des
changements dans le système de santé
alors cela c'est sujet là ont alimenté
le débat de cette campagne électorale on
a hâte comme vous de voir quel sera le
résultat ce soir dans Sherbrooke et
Saint-François et ailleurs également en
esprit on va aller très souvent vous
voir et le simple fait d'avoir choisi
Caroline Saint-Hilaire au kiabète
maintenant en Estrie mais de la part de
la CAQ ça montrait que toutes les
circonscriptions qui ne leur
appartenaient pas on voulait les ravirs
on prenait au sérieux chaque lutte là
que ça soit dans l'Est du Québec on va
en parler dans une seconde ou chez vous
en est ce prix il leur en manque une
exactement très bien merci beaucoup au
revoir oui Sébastien ben c'est clair
qu'on le voit sur la carte et je vous
promets je ne vais utiliser l'expression
village gaulois qu'une seule fois
non plus mais ça illustre Sherbrooke à
quel point c'est un village gaulois
entouré de bleu poudre de la coalition
Québec la circonscription dont on
parlait qui est juste à côté saint
François aussi dans la merde de Québec
solidaire c'est de circonscription et il
est intéressant aussi à cause du tissu
social parce que juste ici ça borde la
ville de Sherbrooke dans plusieurs bains
mais ici c'est beaucoup plus rural alors
ce serait intéressant de voir comment
les gens dans cette circonscription là
de saint François décide de voter
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
similaire entre Sherbrooke et
Rouyn-Noranda dont on a parlé au cours
des dernières minutes des villes où il y
a des universités donc Québec solidaire
mise beaucoup sur le vote sur les campus
il y a un fantasme je vais vous livrer
les fantasmes des parties tout au long
de la soirée quand tu es sur moi un
fantasme ça fait deux oui mais ça je
vais l'utiliser cinq fois c'est très
bien le fantasme de Québec solidaire ce
serait hall ce soir Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois est allé à Old en fin de campagne
électorale on pense avoir un désespoir
il y a l'Université du Québec en
Outaouais dans cette région là aussi
donc le fil conducteur des Persé si on
veut de Québec solidaire à l'extérieur
de l'île de Montréal c'est souvent qu'il
y a des villes universitaires là on me
demande de vous faire voyager Patrice
alors je vais vous faire voyager on va
s'en aller dans ma région chouchou c'est
pas moi qui le veut là c'est la
réalisation en régie donc le
gaspéro Gaspésie mais vous voyez aussi
en haut la côte nord cette région là
avec les Îles de la Madeleine je vous le
rappelle 9 circonscriptions 8
appartiennent aux parties québécois dont
celle-ci de Matane matapedia et on y va
à Matane merci Sébastien Jean-François
Deschamps vous êtes amateur la
circonscription évidemment de Pascal
Bérubé monsieur Legault jour 2 ou 3 de
la campagne avait dit à son candidat qui
se présente comme dérubé avait dit on va
lui donner toute une raide ça donnait le
temps de cette campagne
effectivement effectivement le
présentement je me trouve dans la salle
où vont se rencontrer les partisans de
Pascal Bérubé c'est vite de présentement
mais probablement que ça va être bien
rempli on va voir qui va donner une
raide à qui alors on a bien l'intention
de participer à ça ou en tout cas en
témoigner mais parce que le Bérubé il
faut le rappeler a gagné en 2018 avec
17000 voix de majorité ce qui en dit
long sur la zone sur comment les gens
ici aiment leur ou apprécie leur
candidat pékistes donc ça a pas été une
disons une campagne très très
mouvementée ici dans ma tante Matapédia
si on regarde tout ce qui s'est passé
autour parce que tous les chefs des
grands partis sont venus à Rimouski
Gaspé bonne aventure aux îles ils sont
venus et après qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
ils sont revenus après mais il y a pas
eu beaucoup de visites dans ma tan m'a
tapédia donc peut-être Paul
saint-pierre-flamon donc qui est venu il
y a quelques jours à Sainte-Flavie mais
il y a eu quand même une petite chose là
qui a été bien excitante ici qui a été
intéressante pour les journalistes que
nous sommes c'est lorsque le candidat
libéral s'est fait rejeter sa
candidature par le directeur de scrutin
et bien les libéraux provinciaux ont
déployé l'artillerie lourde pour le
défendre et finalement il a gagné
plusieurs observateurs disent que cette
histoire fera jurisprudence alors
c'était surveillé dans dans 4 ans oui il
a gagné sa présence dans le concours
mais non pas le comté évidemment et dans
Du Plessis du Plessis il y a deux zinous
d'ailleurs ce soir il y a 9
candidats candidates qui proviennent des
Premières nations dont deux Inno dans Du
Plessis
oui c'est une première du Plessis faut
le dire c'est dans le coin de cette île
et la base contenant deux Zino c'est une
première à ce qu'on nous dit dans ce
coin-là une autre première alors
peut-être est-ce que le Parti québécois
sera conservé la circonscription de
Duplessis on le sait que le PQ est au
pouvoir là-bas depuis
1965 alors c'est peut-être un coin à
surveiller aussi c'est facile merci
beaucoup à tout de suite c'est fascinant
de voir la dernière fois en 2018 comment
la vague kakis c'était arrêté à Rimouski
et à l'autre bord à Tadoussac
et le piqûre garder tous les du Québec
oui par la peau des dents un peu aussi
de la Madeleine par quoi 47 voix de
mémoire 15 voix pour Gasper ça avait
chauffé pas mal mais oui on avait réussi
à tenir le fort et si encore un Parti
québécois compétitif entre guillemets ce
soir qui peut espérer garder certains
compter c'est parce que là ça résister
la dernière fois
je pense pas que parce que bébé soit
particulièrement inquiet ce soir mais
ailleurs ailleurs il va avoir des luttes
très intéressantes à suivre oui c'est
intéressant Sébastien prend le vous le
montrer depuis le début c'est quand même
une forteresse acquise par des mines
marges gaspés passer le lendemain qu'on
avait eu le soir de l'élection Mégane
melon avait perdu l'élection candidats
du Parti québécois il y a eu un comptage
judiciaire dans gaspi qui a spécialisé
et finalement il a gagné deux noms en
particulier sa dixième circonscription
ce soir mais quand vous dites que ça
s'arrête net Fred sec c'est ça que vous
avez dit pas tout à fait mais ça voulait
dire on comprend sens vous voyez la la
coalition à venir Québec ici est arrivée
du lootémie squata ensuite au cours du
Sud et tout le Saguenay-Lac-Saint-Jean
et Bleu Poudre sauf la circonscription
de Jonquières qui à part dans l'Est là
est une des deux circonscriptions que le
Parti québécois avait gardé en 2018
l'autre étant Joliette Joliette un
morceau de robot pour moi voilà mais les
huit autres sont dans le Québec donc le
Parti québécois plus gros dans cette
dans cette belle région de l'Est du
Québec notamment
Rimouski madame Matapédia Gaspé
Bonaventure René Lévesque du Plessis
est-ce que vous voyez pas les Îles de la
Madeleine de ce côté-là et on va y aller
à Saguenay parce que s'il fallait au
terme la soirée que le Parti québécois
n'est pas de représentant chaque année
Jean-François Coulon bonsoir ça serait
une première bonsoir oui une première en
50 ans en fait on est dans le dernier
bastion pékiste dans la région et il y a
une chose certes de certaines ce soir
Patrice et qui aura un nouveau ou une
nouvelle député à Jonquières puisque le
député sortant Sylvain Gaudreault ne se
représente pas il était député ici
depuis 15 ans et si le Parti québécois
devait perdre Jonquière et ne faire
aucun gain ailleurs dans la région mais
il y aurait pas de députés pékistes pour
la première fois depuis 50 ans en fait
depuis 1973 le Parti québécois a
toujours fait lire au moins un député
dans la région plus près de nous en 2012
il y a 10 ans les cinq circonscriptions
étaient en restait trois en 2014 une en
2018 on verra ce qui va se passer ici ce
soir pour ravir Jonquière la coalition à
venir Québec mise sur Yannick Gagnon
c'est le directeur du patron de
Jonquières c'est un centre de loisirs
communautaire pour les jeunes bien
connus ici et dont la rénovation avait
été un enjeu important lors de
l'élection de 2018 d'ailleurs François
Legault était venu à ce moment-là au pas
trop de Jonquières rencontré Yannick
Gagnon faut croire qu'il y a eu des
atomes crochus entre les deux le Parti
québécois mise sur Caroline Dubé elle
est la directrice du bureau du député
bloquiste de Jonquières Mario Simard
faudra aussi surveiller le Parti
conservateur qui a voulu faire de la
relance du projet de Gmail Québec la
question de l'urne dans la région et
donc c'est une circonscription très
convoitée la preuve le Premier ministre
sortant François Legault a déclenché
officiellement la campagne électorale
ici même le 28 août dernier et le chef
du Parti québécois Paul Saint-Pierre de
La Mondon a terminé sa campagne
électorale à Jonquières hier après-midi
il m'a d'ailleurs accordé une entrevue
pour Allemagne des derniers entrevues
qu'il a accordé lors de cette campagne
alors ça va être très intéressant de
surveiller ce qui va se passer ici ce
soir et qu'elle sera la réaction du
Parti québécois s'il devait perdre cette
circonscription oui la symbolique est
quand même très forte au Saguenay le
s'il y avait pas de piquer sa voix avoir
les résultats je vous le rappelle
mesdames et messieurs dans 40 minutes on
aura les ça sera la fermeture des
bureaux du scrutin on aura les premiers
résultats Sébastien la carte les
tableaux on va aller à vitesse grand V
vitesse grand V pour vous livrer de
façon la plus claire possible tous les
résultats et la carte de Sébastien va se
colorer selon les les désirs de la
population dans chaque circonscription
et c'est vous qui décidez on a beaucoup
parlé nous tous les politiciens ont
beaucoup parlé pendant 36 jours mais
aujourd'hui c'était la population qui
elle parlait on verra le résultat donc à
partir de maintenant en principe c'est
le vote par anticipation qui est
dépouillé en premier donc on devrait
quand même avoir des résultats assez
rapidement mais le DG tout à l'heure
vous a dit 20h45 il m'a répété deux fois
20h45
qu'on aurait mais qu'on arrive
du vote participation mais il a dit mais
en même temps on commence à 6h à compter
donc mais comme le vote par anticipation
a été historique extrêmement élevé on
devrait avoir quand même beaucoup de
résultats assez rapidement il y a 24 %
des Québécois qui ont voté mais comme
100% n'auront pas voter en réalité on a
un électeur sur trois qui c'est déjà
prononcé dans le vote par anticipation
donc ça va donner quand même une
indication de l'allure de la soirée très
bien ça va coup de joie
une circonscription qui vote peu
à 17h30 je crois que c'était vous aviez
le pire score
oui un taux de participation qui est
historiquement mais ça pourrait changer
Patrice cette année parce qu'il y a deux
candidats autochtones qui créent
énormément d'intérêts dans leur
communauté respective je voulais
présente rapidement mettez la break
saganage d'abord de Québec solidaire qui
est la fille de l'ancien député Romeo
saganache une militante très connu dans
sa communauté et qui affront donc tous
nous n'appartoque du Parti libéral du
Québec un Inno qui est l'ancien maire de
coup de jouaque une autre figure très
connue ici dans sa communauté et dans la
circonscription deux candidats donc qui
vont tenter de renverser cette tendance
là d'un désintérêt envers la politique
provinciale j'ai les chiffres ici en
2018 lors du dernier scrutin dans
l'ensemble de la circonscription d'une
Gava on comptait environ 30% d'un taux
de participation mais dans les
communautés inoïdes écrit là c'est un
taux qui descendait sous la barre des
20% et parfois sous la barre des 15%
dans la majorité des communauté un des
intérêts qui est dû à plusieurs facteurs
mais notamment la barrière de la langue
ou le cri les noukitoute et prédominant
suivi de l'anglais donc tous les
messages de campagne en français ont
peut-être un peu plus de mal à se rendre
ici ensemble ici au nord et il y a aussi
un certain sentiment de ne pas être bien
représenté à l'Assemblée nationale au
moins je suis une partie de l'électorale
autochtone ici il voudrait un député qui
vient de leur communauté qui comprend
leur réalité donc ces deux
candidatures-là qui suscitent énormément
d'intérêt dans les communautés
autochtones qui représentent environ 65%
il faut le dire de l'électorat de la
circonscription d'une Gava c'est de loin
la proportion des lecteurs autochtones
la plus élevée partout dans parmi les
autres circonscriptions de la province
le reste de l'électorat à l'automne est
concentré plus au sud de la
circonscription dans le territoire de la
Baie James
territoire là que les autres candidats
sont concentrés leurs efforts de
campagne il y a notamment Denis Lamotte
une coalition à venir Québec qui veut
briguer un second mandat qui avait été
élu en 2018 avec seulement 46 voix
d'avance sur le Parti québécois le Parti
québécois qui a nommé cette année
Christine more une ancienne députée
fédérale du NPD dans la circonscription
d'habitivité musculaire et finalement
Nancy a lancé du Parti conservateur du
Québec qui a donné une campagne très
discrète que pratiquement pas été
visible sur le terrain donc vraiment
Patrice la question ce soir qui va être
déterminante pour le vote ici dans Gava
pour les résultats dans Gama c'est
est-ce que les communautés autochtones
vont sortir voter c'est ce qu'on va
suivre ce soir c'est exactement la
question que je voulais poser à Manon
merci beaucoup à m'annoncer parce que
oui ils veulent davantage représentés
pour les comprend tout à fait en même
temps ils ne vont pas beaucoup voter
effectivement et ça m'étonne toujours de
voir parce que là vous avez deux
candidats un du côté de coup de jouet
une du côté droit ça devrait susciter
l'intérêt du vote mais ce qu'il faut se
rappeler lorsque ont été votés l'année
passée pour leur grand chef madame
mendygone masti 35% de taux de
participation alors je pense pour que ce
soit il va avoir un SIO taux de
participation malheureusement mais moi
je trouve ça bien qu'au moins les gens
veulent participer et un gavotte depuis
les dernières années les communautés
crient toltones et une nuitée prennent
plus de place mais votre moins donc ça
fait un tour de participation on a plus
bas possible c'est comme un Lambre
processus de tendre la main puis
peut-être dans trois quatre élections ça
va être la dynamique va être différents
il faut savoir que la loi électorale
permet des bureaux de vote itinérant
adaptés au
mais dans les différentes communautés un
peu plus que ceci est permis et même
auprès des sites miniers ou dans
différents secteurs éloignés de la
région donc moi je croyais que la charge
pouvait avoir un effet négatif mais on
me dit que c'est pas nécessairement il y
a des particuliers Québec solidaire
déployé une organisatrice que 75 ans 75
ans l'organisatrice de Québec solidaire
qui est à l'origine des victoires de
Vincent Maricel et americadia dans le
temps donc on met le paquet pour QS dans
cette sessions faut savoir aussi que
monsieur Legault est venu déjà dans la
dernière année dans le dernier Mado 5
fois Monsieur Gabriel Nadaud Dubois est
venu au début il est venu au début de la
campagne madame vous avez vu en fin de
semaine les gestes questionner pourquoi
avoir coup de jouet mais si vous voulez
susciter l'intérêt faut aller en région
même si c'est relativement peu de vote
très bien on va aller on fait un saut
éclair à Gatineau Rosalie Saint-Clair
c'est la circonscription de Hall qu'on
surveille
ouais circonscription qui libérale
depuis plusieurs années qui a été
libérale depuis 1956 autre une percée du
Parti québécois 1976 c'est Maryse
Gaudreault qui détient la
circonscription depuis 2008 et je vous
le rappelle lors des dernières élections
en 2018 la CAQ qui avait fait une percée
en Outaouais qui avait remporté trois
des cinq circonscriptions alors hall
certainement qu'on va la surveiller au
courant de la soirée ça a été le cas
pendant toute la campagne on sait qu'en
outaoui il y a la proximité avec
l'Ontario donc il y a eu la question de
la main d'oeuvre dans le milieu de la
santé ces travailleurs de la santé qui
vont en Ontario pour travailler avoir de
meilleurs salaires de meilleures
conditions salariales donc ça a été un
des enjeux discutés en Outaouais alors
voilà cette conscription de haul qui
appartient au parti libérale du Québec
qui sera à surveiller certainement
est-ce que cette circonscription passera
du rouge au bleu ce sera suivra avec les
résultats ce soir déjà que de poser la
question c'est déjà c'est déjà quelque
chose là parce que
en 2018 donc pendant toute la campagne
les yeux ont vraiment été rêvé sur la
circonscription de all laka qui a
présenté sa candidate Suzanne Tremblay
qui était président du syndicat des
enseignants de l'outawa alors quand même
un visage connu dans la région très bien
merci à plus tard au revoir oui luttaway
ils sont tous allés évidemment mais
c'est déjà qu'on en parle comme un autre
il y avait une première percée dans la
nature une deuxième dans la mine de tout
le monde à la fois la coalition Québec
solidaire il y a la circonscription de
Hall ici contient qu'on en parle pas
parce qu'on pense que André Fortin est
très bien assis sur cette
circonscription là il devrait être élu
mais dans un il va y avoir une bataille
et je définis juste pour le bénéfice de
tout le monde le mot fantasme que
j'utilise c'est si ça va très très très
bien pour Québec solidaire ce soir donc
ils sont vraiment en gains ils pensent
peut-être avoir une chance dans elle
mais la carte aussi les libéraux la
beauté de la chose savez-vous quoi
Sébastien on va voir les vrais chiffres
dans 30 minutes donc on va passer du
fantasme à la réalité
c'est ce que tout le monde veut très
bien
très bien alors dans je vous avertis
tout de suite que dans oui 31 minutes
les bureaux ferment dans quelques
minutes on va accueillir les
téléspectateurs de Radio-Canada alors
les gens RD oui vous allez réentendre
certaines choses mais on va essayer de
les dire autrement Sébastien plein de
mots dans sa besace et on est en forme
on a réchauffé le plateau ça va être une
très belle soirée électorale moi je peux
vous dire que j'ai très très hâte au
premier résultat est-ce que ça sera les
idées de la Madeleine le vent du large
souvent ça arrive en premier mais ce
n'est pas à chaque fois les îles alors
on se retrouve l'autre côté de ceci
devenir voter peu importe pour qu'elle
parte on va donner ma voix à une
personne qui va être en place pour nous
représenter et c'est notre
responsabilité parce que c'est important
pour la démocratie est-ce que c'est
important pour faire notre comme tout le
monde dit la fameuse classique parce que
c'est notre devoirs
pour toutes les générations pour bâtir
le futur
avec votre fille oui en même temps on
parle c'est quoi ça voter c'est notre
droit fondamental puis je pense que dans
une démocratie forte exacée de droite
ben si signe que la démocratie est en
santé on a devoir les résultats
[Musique]
ce sont dans notre histoire des soirées
importantes
[Musique]
les électeurs de chez nous mon ordre de
leur confiance et le confinement de
présenter leurs intérêts
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a plus de maintenant ou jamais ce
soir nous devons dire c'est maintenant
que nous deviendrons maître chez nous
Québec d'abord c'est un appel à la
coopération de tous les Québécois pour
relancer le Québec sur la voie du vrai
progrès
l'avenir de notre pays se trouvant en
jeu nous sommes bien équipés pour
relever ces défis et pour faire face aux
priorités du Québec
j'ai jamais pensé que je pouvais être
aussi fier d'être Québécois que ce soit
[Applaudissements]
ensemble relevons ce Québec pour qu'elle
nous sommes tellement attachés à
Bordeaux ce nouveau chapitre de notre
histoire
[Applaudissements]
réaliser leurs aspirations
aujourd'hui au Québec on s'est donné un
gouvernement du 21e siècle nous sommes
prêts pour la première fois le
gouvernement du Québec sera dirigé par
une femme
enfin nous pouvons tout réussir nous
allons tout réussir
aujourd'hui
on a marqué l'histoire
[Musique]
et juste un mot à vous de créer
on repart les compteurs à zéro
et on est à un moment décisif c'est
l'élection de la dernière chance si vous
êtes en train de faire l'histoire quel
avenir pour notre destin
nous vivons la 43e élection générale au
Québec ces joutes électorales sont des
repères des marqueurs dans l'histoire
les cinq chefs vous ont présenté des
visions très différentes ils ont plaidé
ils ont débattu ici même ils ont
beaucoup parlé depuis 36 jours ce soir
ils attendent votre réponse bienvenue à
votre soirée électorale
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice Roy et toute l'équipe de
l'information de Radio-Canada très
heureux de vous accueillir encore une
fois dans l'atrium de cette nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada sur notre
nouvelle place publique Sébastien Bovet
bonsoir
oui
on se le cachera pas les gens disent
puis on a parlé à tous les jours de
cette campagne on sait bien qui va
gagner il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
croyait savoir que ce sont pas avérés
dans cette campagne il y a quand même eu
des surprises et il reste des questions
fort importantes il reste des questions
à faire importantes notamment de savoir
qui sera l'opposition qui pourrait être
l'opposition officielle à partir du
moment où on pense que la coalition
amenée Québec va l'emporter mais en même
temps c'est vous qui dessinez la carte
de qui coloriait la carte électorale au
Québec donc le choix des Québécois
aujourd'hui se sont exprimés depuis 36
jours vous nous avez beaucoup entendu
nous parler les politiciens parler mais
aujourd'hui c'était aux gens de
s'exprimer Chantal Hébert allait
castonguet bonsoir merci d'être ici avec
nous
Chantal qu'est-ce que vous allez
surveiller ce soir en particulier
cinq parties est-ce qu'il y aura cinq
chefs à l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que on n'échappe pas cette question là
surtout pour des parties qui auront pas
nécessairement des immenses cocus et
donc si écrase leur cou ce soir pas
beaucoup de gens qui pourraient leur
céder un siège pour qu'ils s'essaye pour
rentrer à l'Assemblée nationale et pour
un parti je pense en particulier aux
parties conservateur particulier avoir
un chef à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
une condition presque essentielle pour
pouvoir bâtir un meilleur résultat dans
quatre ans et c'est rare il faut le
souligner comme vous êtes que trois des
cinq chefs mais d'abord c'est rare que 5
chefs
1976 il y avait cinq parties mais pas
vraiment c'est la première fois depuis
Mathusalem oh c'est rare que trois
dessins peuvent ne pas entrer bref
c'est en fait même au fédéral on sait
pas vraiment posé de questions sur Jack
meeting Elizabeth May ces gens là
passaient dans leur circonscription
c'est ça parle c'est un signe d'État au
Québec on la carte électorale continue
de bouger en 2018 quand on était pas sur
la même plateau c'était moins beau
la carte passe mais est-ce que on va
revenir à la normale les libéraux le
Parti québécois c'est pas ça qui s'est
passé et ça explique comment on a cette
dynamique électorale vraiment
particulière très bien Alec vous
surveillez quoi ce soir beaucoup
beaucoup de batailles régionales
intéressantes dans le bas du fleuve en
Gaspésie en Estrie l'île de Montréal
l'île de Montréal va avoir des batailles
intéressantes c'est pas souvent le cas
Laval aussi figé souvent depuis des
décennies lavalles pourraient bouger ce
soir en outai ouais pour y avoir des des
surprises à Rouen Noranda ça va être
surveillé donc à peu près tout le Québec
va être à surveillé pour des raisons
différentes et ce qui va être décidé ce
soir on va avoir un impact pendant les
quatre prochaines années la dynamique
des parties un en croissance un à
décroissance est-ce qu'un chef est là ou
non il y a un impact à nationale et sur
la dynamique du paysage politique
québécois et c'est les élections où on
tranche dynamique vous faites la preuve
que même si le gagnant on peut le
présumer il y a des questions
extrêmement intéressantes et il y a des
points d'interrogation qui sont là et on
va répondre le peuple va répondre à ça
en partie je le disais tout à l'heure on
a décidé cette année mesdames et
messieurs d'amener un peu de Québec un
peu de Montréal et un peu des régions
sur le plateau et de pas d'avoir d'ex
nécessairement de partie mais d'exmère
on a deux actions et une mairesse
actuelle Régis labom mère de Québec
expert de Québec Manon aussi mais reste
de Shibu Gamo et Luc Ferrandez ex je
referai pas deux fois la même blague
mère du Plateau Mont-Royal bonsoir à
vous trois bonsoir merci d'être là donc
c'est intéressant vous êtes bien
enraciné vous connaissez votre milieu
tour de table rapide vous surveille quoi
on sent définitivement du bipartisme ou
du tripartisme on a un modèle plus
européen dépendant pardonnez-moi je vais
on a des images qui viennent d'entrer de
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon qui écoute
donc la soirée électorale a Boucherville
ils sont réunis les pékistes dans un
hôtel de Boucherville Maurice et
Lorraine et le raide pardonnez-moi on
voit sa chef de cabinet également avec
lui donc c'est traditionnel tous les
chefs ne se sont pas prêtés au jeu cette
année mais il y a des prises d'images
pendant le début de la soirée après ils
disent merci bonsoir On va écouter la
soirée plus tranquillement donc voilà
Régis on est dans une vraie gauche et
une vraie droite et évidemment moi c'est
Québec
le Parti conservateur est né à Québec la
question est-ce qu'il est
sous-estimé dans les sondages comme le
sont souvent les parties de droite aussi
le plafonner ou quelque chose très
produit lorsque on a appris que Monsieur
James ne payait pas ses factures alors
c'est la grande question
lui se présente lui-même actuellement ne
pas le meilleur résultat dans la région
de troisième résultat à part les deux
bosses ce serait très intéressant je
n'ai l'impression que c'est pour monter
ça va monter dans plusieurs côtés en
même temps très bien maintenant vos
premières impressions alors vous allez
me permettre de saluer les gens
donnez-moi ce soir sa première fois
depuis longtemps que j'étais à Montréal
au lieu de chez nous pour rester la
soirée nationale mais définitivement je
vais quand même surveiller ou un Orada
tes muscaman étant donné le contexte
avec la fonderie est-ce qu'il s'est
passé et on verra pour la suite et je
suis toujours un petit peu anxieuse de
voir le taux de participation je me dis
qu'au Québec on devrait voter surtout
quand on a une palette de couleur celle
que de dire assez quand même important
là pour avoir du choix pour les citoyens
le vote est un peu puis je vais vous le
montrer tout à l'heure dans quelques
secondes mais le vote c'est un peu plus
élevé c'est quand même une nouvelle
intéressante Luc à il y a deux choses à
surveiller premièrement est-ce que la
CAC va devoir gouverner 4 ans sans
candidats forts dans Montréal les thèmes
que la carte aborde l'immigration le
développement économique la langue etc
si on n'a pas déjà de Montréal qui sont
forts pour parler au Conseil des
ministres ils vont avoir ils vont être
en déficit de crédibilité la deuxième
chose ce qui va se passer à Montréal
avec les parties d'opposition va
déterminer ce qui va se passer dans 4
ans est-ce que les libéraux vont être
confinés à des compter uniquement
anglophones est-ce que le Parti
québécois va garder une une position va
rentrer à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
que QS va pour la première fois
décroître ou va continuer de croître
très bien alors le point de départ de
tout ça je vous le montre mesdames et
messieurs la CAC à la dissolution non
pas la dernière élection maladie
solution avait 76 députés le PLQ
27qs 10 qui est le même score qu'ils
avaient eu lors de l'élection générale
ils ont pas eu de changement il y a pas
eu essentiel il y a pas eu de départ le
Parti québécois 7 plutôt que les 10 élus
la dernière fois quatre indépendants et
le Parti conservateur du Québec vous le
savez il y a eu un une transfuge qui a
permis à Éric duem d'avoir d'être
représenté à l'Assemblée nationale
majorité 63 vous allez je vais vous le
montrer quand ils vont apparaître vous
allez avoir le nombre en tout temps 63
c'est pour obtenir une majorité monsieur
Legault avait largement une majorité la
dernière fois et on verra jusqu'où il
ira toute participation
44,6 donc 45%, c'est à 17 heures en
comparaison il était à 41% à 16 heures
en 2018 donc on peut penser on peut
penser qu'il y a un peu plus de gens qui
sont allés voter à voir c'est pas c'est
pas nécessairement comme ça l'an dernier
je vous le rappelle l'an dernier 2018 il
y avait eu 66 % le taux de participation
au Québec et on jugeait que c'est
vraiment trop bas donc les gens espèrent
que ça regrimpe en haut du 70 parce
qu'elle point est là elle parlant de
vote vous êtes à Québec devant un bureau
de vote ouvert encore pendant 19 minutes
vous êtes dans la circonscription de
Jean Le Sage
Jean Le Sage actuellement détenu par
sols génétique tente de se faire réalire
pour Quebec solidaire et c'est une
circonscription qu'on a choisi parce que
ici c'est intéressant les enjeux de
transport on a beaucoup parlé du
troisième lien du tunnel entre Québec et
les vies durant la campagne électorale
or ici c'est du très concret pour les
électeurs parce que la sortie
centre-ville du côté de Québec ben ce
serait dans la circonscription de Jean
Lesage où tout à côté là parce que c'est
dans le secteur Soumande alors donc le
tunnel verrait sa sortie là dans la
circonscription où on se trouve en même
temps il y a aussi le tramway qui passe
par ici une circonscription qui est
composée du secteur de lime à l'eau qui
va un peu plus à gauche prend plus le
transport en commun puis du secteur
Beauport peut-être plus au centre ou à
droite les gens sont plus dépendants de
la voiture et justement le tramway la
coalition va venir Québec a changé le
trajet dans la circonscription devait
passer d'un secteur Limoilou pour monter
à Charlesbourg on l'a transféré pour
qu'il aille vers l'est alors qu'est-ce
que les électeurs vont choisir comment
vont-ils analyser situation c'est son
pour le tunnel contre le tunnel ça
risque de faire changer aussi leur vote
alors ici vraiment il y a des impacts
concrets à toute cette question du
troisième lien à toute cette caption
également des transports en commun dans
la ville de Québec et Dieu sait qu'on a
beaucoup parlé du troisième livre dans
cette campagne il y a des gens qui en
pouvaient plus que fermer la télé ils
arrêtaient je recevais des courriels
d'insultes vraiment vous manquez
d'imagination mais on a c'est que les
journalistes de partout ont posé la
question vous riez justement mais c'est
vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé de votre
troisième lien mais moi j'étais un petit
peu tanné
on revient toujours
il y avait des cachoteries à la limite
potentiellement des mensonges il y avait
quelque chose d'important en termes
d'éthique là en terme politique alors je
les comprends je trouve qu'effectivement
dans le bon coin bon alors on verra on
va continuer à en parler je le sens
Mathieu proche vous êtes à Montréal dans
un bureau de vote dans
circonscription le chef du Parti
québécois se présente
on est dans un bureau proche de celui où
Paul saint-pierre-la-mondron a voté un
peu plus tôt ce matin puis on l'a vu
après dans une vidéo en larmes avec sa
fille dans les bras faire un appel à ses
militants à son organisation pour aller
motiver les électeurs à aller exercer
leurs droits de vote alors est-ce que
les électeurs ont été mobilisés ici je
viens de raccrocher avec le directeur
général des élections qui me dit que la
participation à 16h ici
44,5% donc en fait c'est un tout petit
peu en dessous de la moyenne nationale à
16h le vote qui s'établissait à
44,6%, ça ça inclut tout le vote par
anticipation qui a été comptabilisé
aussi vous savez il y a aussi le fait
que ce vote par anticipation gagne en
popularité 98 par exemple c'était 5%
2007 10% 2012 16% à peu près puis donc
en 2022 le vote par anticipation 24,4%
donc il y a moins de personnes qui
exercent leur droit de vote le jour du
scrutin et on le voit dans les bureaux
de vote puisqu'il y a moins de fil
d'attente en fait il n'y a pas de file
d'attente c'est assez fluide un peu
partout il y a une hausse effectivement
de la participation par anticipation pas
trop de problèmes on nous signale des
pannes d'électricité dans certains
bureaux de vote dans une circonscription
qui est proche de celle-ci ici dans la
gare mais le vote se poursuit quand même
jusqu'à 20h avec des génératrices donc
fluides pas de problème de personnel on
craignait qu'il y ait moins de
scrutateurs ou de secrétaire pour
accueillir les électeurs mais en fait
tout le monde s'est bien organisé on a
formé du personnel jusqu'à hier pour
s'assurer que tout fonctionne
aujourd'hui et le résultat c'est que
tout fonctionne effectivement plutôt
bien merci Mathieu et le directeur
général des élections qui était sur nos
ondes plutôt RDI nous a dit bon c'était
effectivement un débrouillé devant
l'absence de main d'oeuvre dans
certaines circonscriptions deux que le
vote par anticipation qui a quand même
été très fort historiquement fort et
compter depuis 18 heures lui nous
parlait d'une avalanche de résultats à
20h45 mais on comprend que les premiers
résultats que vous allez entendre avec
nous c'est le vote par anticipation
beaucoup donc pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que dans certains de
circonscriptions ça fait pas de
différence dans d'autres ça peut être
une grande différence les gens qui
votentation ne votent pas nécessairement
comme les gens qui suivent plus tard
Sébastien Bovet on le disait Alex le
disait il y a vraiment Montréal c'est
fascinant Québec c'est fascinant
l'esprit c'est fascinant l'as du Québec
c'est facile il y a plein de vrais
luttes et comme c'est moi qui contrôle
la carte je vous amène d'abord dans ma
région chouchou ça va ma région chouchou
c'est
Barça Laurent Gaspésie en fait c'est
beaucoup plus l'Est du Québec en tant
que tel en incluant la côte nord aussi
dans cette région là il y a combien de
circonscriptions il y en a 9 combien
appartiennent aux parties québécois 8
donc ça passe ou ça casse dans cette
région là pour le Parti québécois qui
espère conserver la majorité de ces
circonscriptions incluant les îles de la
semaines qu'on ne voit pas sur la carte
je vous mon tour du Québec vous amène
plus à l'ouest la région de Régis la
Baume la mienne aussi je revendique que
c'est aussi ma région dans laquelle on
va surveiller le Parti conservateur en
particulier où dans Chauveau la
circonscription dans laquelle Eric James
le chef du Parti conservateur se
présente on verra donc s'il réussi à se
faire élire dans cette circonscription
là mais si on arrive Sud aussi deux
circonscriptions bosnor les militants du
parti conservateur on dit iridien on n'a
pas besoin de toi pendant la campagne
électorale il a quand même senti le
besoin d'y aller hier pour la dernière
journée de campagne et bosse Sud où les
conservateurs pensent aussi avoir des
chances de l'emporter ensuite
je vous amener dans un endroit où je
vous amène pas souvent dans les soirées
électorales l'île de Montréal vous
l'avez dit ce sera un enjeu l'île de
Montréal cette fois-ci combien de
circonscriptions sur l'île de Montréal
27 10
27 comme ça
il y en a combien qui appartiennent au
Parti libéral 19 puis d'habitude on en
parle pas parce que c'est réglé d'avance
les libéraux conservent tout l'Ouest
Québec Solidaire est au centre puis le
bleu que vous voyez d'un
traditionnellement c'est le bleu du
Parti québécois dans l'Est mais là c'est
le bleu de la coalition à venir Québec
le bleu poudre qui s'est installé aux
dernières élections la question qu'on va
se poser c'est ici au centre quelles
circonscription pourrait être chaudement
débattu on parle notamment de Maurice
Richard de Verdun ici
Henri Sainte-Anne qui est la
circonscription de Madame de Madame la
chef du Parti libéral et finalement je
vous amène dans une de vos régions
chouchous Laval combien de
circonscription à Laval 6 combien
libérale 5 en 2018 là le la coalition à
venir Québec espère que au fil au bout
de la soirée on aura inversé ce résultat
la coalition Québec aimerait bien avoir
5 et 6 circonscriptions à la fin de la
soirée très bien merci Sébastien Mathieu
proche nous parlait de panne
d'électricité mais dans Notre Dame de
Grâce il y a trois bureaux de vote qui
sont qui sont fermés en fait qui sont
interrompus en interrompu le déroulement
du vote contenu qui a pas d'électricité
alors pourtant il fait un temps
magnifique mais c'est comme ça il y a
une panne d'électricité dans Notre Dame
de Grâce ailleurs aussi une disait-on
alors on va suivre ça pour vous
dans des écoles pardon c'est parce qu'on
fait les bureaux de vote dans les écoles
en effet le déficit de maintenance dans
les écoles et de 50%. au Québec
on va suivre ça je disais ceux qui ont
suivi cette campagne de A à Z nos
journalistes sur le terrain qui suivent
les cinq parties Véronique prince est
avec laque alexandre Duval avec le Parti
libéral Valérie Gamache avec Québec
solidaire Sébastien Desrosiers avec le
Parti québécois et Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau avec le Parti conservateur
bonsoir à vous cinq je commence avec
vous Véronique vous êtes au théâtre
Capitole à Québec où monsieur Legault et
la cas ont décidé de faire le
rassemblement ce soir
il est avec sa famille ses deux garçons
en ce moment sa conjointe Isabelle brin
dans une chambre atteint d'écouter la
soirée électorale un petit peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui s'est rendu au quartier
général de la région de Québec pour
prononcer un discours encouragé ses
bénévoles
ça va être important de rassembler après
la campagne électorale de rassembler les
gens de toutes les origines alors
référence à la question de l'immigration
des plaies à monsieur Legault il en a
parlé plus qu'il ne l'aurait voulu dans
cette campagne électorale là notamment
par sa faute parce qu'on se rappelle du
moment où il a dit que d'augmenter les
seuils d'immigration ce serait
suicidaire ça c'était pas prévu c'était
pas dans le discours c'était dans une
entrevue avec le président de la Chambre
de commerce mais à partir du moment où
l'a dit son équipe s'est dit on va
l'assumer c'est correct sauf que c'est
arrivé en même temps qu'ils ont su
qu'elles étaient les propos du ministre
Jean Boulay prononcé dans un dans un
débat une semaine plutôt où il disait
que 80% des immigrants étaient à
Montréal par les pas français n'adhérent
aux valeurs et ça ça les a vraiment pris
au dépourvu parce que si l'équipe de
Monsieur boulet les avait avertis ils
auraient pu recadrer le message avoir un
genre de plantes contingence organisé de
tourner l'entrevue mais il s'attendait
pas du tout à ça et ça a été quand même
une mauvaise journée qui a marqué leur
fin de campagne un extrait qu'on peut
aller écouter
une campagne électorale qu'on le veuille
ou non surtout quand il y a 5 parties
c'est divisé
tout le monde essaye de se distinguer de
s'attaquer on est vu une coupe
m'attaquer depuis 5 semaines là je m'y
attendais mais on a beau s'y attendre
mais je suis resté de bonne humeur
alors Véronique il est il est il est en
train d'écouter bien sûr la soirée puis
il attend comme nous les résultats dans
8 minutes ce qu'on aura des images de de
lui et de sa famille
oui on les aura vers 20h15 20h30 très
bien merci beaucoup Véronique à tout de
suite on s'en va voir alexandre Duval à
Montréal au Théâtre Corona avec les
libéraux Dominique englade elle a besoin
que son vote là
première moitié de campagne de Madame
anglais n'a pas été facile la deuxième
moitié a été meilleur mais il y a une
chose qui est restée content constante à
travers toute la campagne c'est que les
militants libéraux ont les chercher dans
bien des rassemblements parfois ils
étaient une dizaine des fois une
vingtaine mais jamais vraiment plus que
quelques dizaines et là ça pose toutes
sortes de questions où sont-ils ces
militants là est-ce que la marque de
commerce libéral est toujours aussi
forte qu'avant est-ce que Dominique
Anglade est parvenu à faire prendre aux
parties libérales le virage qu'elle
voulait lui faire prendre et je vous
dirais que le résultat qu'on aura ce
soir répondra peut-être en partie à ces
questions là madame Anglade espère des
gains à l'extérieur de l'île de Montréal
en même temps il faut qu'elle fasse il
faut qu'elle sécurise
photo fort et ça c'est pas gagné il y a
peut-être des luttes qui vont nous
garder éveiller très tard ce soir et la
clé pour elle c'est effectivement que
ces électeurs libéraux se rendent aux
urnes mais il y a rien de gagner si on
les voyait pas sur le terrain pourquoi y
aurait-il voter aujourd'hui la machine
libérale était vraiment en marche
aujourd'hui juste pour vous donner une
idée là il y a eu près de 100 000 appels
téléphoniques qui ont été faits dans
seulement 20 compter pour inciter ces
électeurs là à se rendre aux urnes
aujourd'hui malgré tout vous allez
l'entendre madame Anglade elle est très
sereine
j'ai le sentiment d'avoir tout donné
dans cette campagne d'avoir mis toutes
les idées de la vente d'avoir été
d'avoir été à l'écoute aussi et d'avoir
été moi-même d'abord et avant tout
d'avoir été moi-même puis donc c'est
pour ça que je suis je vais avec ce
sentiment du devoir du devoir accompli
aujourd'hui
très bien tout de suite oui
au Théâtre Corona un petit peu plus tard
vers 21h et on aura j'imagine aussi des
images merci beaucoup à tout de suite
Valérie gamma je vais être au MT2 à
Montréal également avec Québec solidaire
ouais et là les militants commencent à
arriver ici une fois le ces jeunes je
vous dirais on est déjà un petit peu
plus tôt d'ailleurs qu'il y avait une
file sur la rue Sainte-Catherine pour
assister à ce rassemblement mais il est
temps on attend peut-être 1500 personnes
mais Gabriel à nous Dubois lui en
quelque sorte manqué ces dernières
apparition publique aujourd'hui parce
que le seul moment où on pouvait donc
rencontrer le chef où il aurait pu faire
un appel aux électeurs c'était au bureau
de scrutin au moment où il se rendait
voter mais la directrice de scooter dans
Gwen n'a pas vraiment voulu que les
journalistes astuces à ce moment elle a
accepté que les caméras ils soient mais
les obtenus à l'écart et donc on a eu
quelques images de Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
mais vraiment avec cette dame là qui est
interposante les caméras et la boîte de
scrutin et ça fait en sorte qu'elle nous
a pour chasser jusqu'à à l'extérieur de
ce bureau de scrutin et qui Gabriel
n'ado Dubois finalement n'a pas pu faire
lamelle est presque il avait prévu faire
je sentais ce qu'il a eu le temps de
nous dire et également les excuses que
Pierre Reed a présenté au nom du
directeur général des élections de son
bureau donc ou un peu plus tôt à
l'émission je vous laisse donc entendre
Gabriel nado Dubois et Pierre-Louis
ça c'est très bien passé
j'ai fait mon choix pour la
circonscription de Gouin
directeur général des élections
générales de responsabilités et je suis
désolé de la situation de ce matin et je
présente mes excuses au journaliste qui
était présent je pense que les règles
devront être revu réévaluer parce que
pour son équité là quant à la couverture
médiatique pour tous les candidats
en tout cas cette dame va s'en souvenir
longtemps et je disais on l'a pas nommé
on voulait pas de l'accablir elle
pensait bien faire mais disons que ça
allait contre une grande tradition
depuis
qu'il y a de la télévision merci
beaucoup à tout de suite Sébastien
Desrosiers vous êtes à l'Hôtel Mortagne
à Boucherville c'est là que le Parti
québécois décide de tenir son
rassemblement
ouais vous l'avez vu un peu plus tôt
Paul saint-pierre-plamondon est dans un
salon avec sa famille regarde la soirée
électorale ici ça ne fait que commencer
alors il est un peu tôt pour dire
qu'elle est l'ambiance mais aujourd'hui
en tout cas l'ambiance était bonne Paul
St Pierre lamandon quand il s'est rendu
voté semblait heureux disait le ciel est
bleu bleu PQ on l'imagine vous
souviendrait sans doute qu'il avait
prédit au début de la campagne que le
Parti québécois serait l'équipe
Cendrillon du tournoi il estime avoir
mené une bonne campagne ça être fait
connaître notamment grâce au débat et on
a senti sur le terrain une vague de
sympathie envers lui la question c'est
de savoir est-ce que cette vague de
sympathie va se transformer en vote ce
soir ou comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
sinon le carrosse de Cendrillon pourrait
se transformer en citrouille il a dit un
peu plus tôt aujourd'hui que le taux de
participation sera important quand il
est allé encourager remercier ses
bénévoles dans son local électoral de
Camille lorrain il a d'ailleurs retrouvé
sa famille à ce moment-là qu'il n'avait
pas beaucoup vu depuis un mois il a
semblé fatigué derniers jours et vous
savez parfois les émotions prennent le
dessus à ces moments-là alors Mathieu
vous en avez parlé un peu plus tôt voici
cet extrait où le chef du PQ s'adresse à
ces militants
ça a été une campagne
très belle
c'est une campagne dont on peut être
très fière fait aujourd'hui ce qui nous
reste c'est de d'aller vers les gens les
inciter à voter
avec la petite Lorette je crois que j'ai
dit un autre nom tout à l'heure
mais je me suis repris Laurette c'est
Laurette effectivement
merci
Jacques audrais vous êtes au Manoir du
Lac de l'âge à Québec dans le comté de
Chauveau et c'est un vrai test pour Éric
Duhem
absolument c'est l'objectif numéro 1
qu'il
se fait facile dans Chauveau la lutte va
être chaude avec le député quelques
sortant Sylvain Lévesque on nous dit du
côté de Monsieur Duhem qui les confiant
et qu'il veut causer des surprises parce
que le vote conservateur est un peu
difficile à estimer selon lui parce
qu'on n'a pas de comparatif
rappelez-vous en 2018 le Parti
conservateur a récolté 1,46% des voix 60
000 votes environ il compte autant de
membres aujourd'hui donc pour Éric Duhem
le mot d'ordre c'est que c'est une
victoire peu importe qui va se passer
évidemment on veut faire élire des
députés on a les yeux rivés sur beau Sud
bosnord dans les rêves les plus fous des
conservateurs on pourrait débordés vers
Bellechasse arrivé deuxième aussi dans
des circonscriptions dans shutter à
Palach ou encore à Québec ce serait une
victoire pour iridium ça préparait la
prochaine élection en 2026 aujourd'hui
le dit qu'il était en fait satisfait du
fait que le taux de participation pour
le vote par anticipation était ça
pourrait lui servir écoutons et réduire
notre profil d'électeur est un profil
qui normalement traditionnellement votre
moins et mais cette fois-ci les motiver
donc est-ce que ça peut changer quelque
chose moi je pense que c'est pas le fait
que par exemple le bureau de vote par
anticipation ont connu plus de succès
cette année je pense que c'est pas
étranger à notre montée le fait que
c'est dans la région de Québec une chose
qui est sûr c'est sûr que tu en as
peut-être pas le même stress que les
autres parties parce qu'on est la seule
formation politique aujourd'hui qui est
certaine de faire mieux que la dernière
fois ça je pense que personne qui peut
contester ça de notre part
très bien j'encoudrer merci il l'a
répété à plusieurs reprises depuis
quelques jours il dit peu importe le
résultat il prépare son monde aussi ses
militants à ce qui a peut-être zéro un
député monsieur on est parti de un point
6 %, on est à 10 11 12 on verra 13 où ça
va se terminer alors voilà madame et
Messieurs
les vrais affaires commencent dans
exactement 5 secondes on va fermer les
bureaux de scrutin
[Musique]
alors ça y est il est 20h les jeux sont
faits les votes sont dans les boîtes et
on va recevoir très rapidement les
premiers résultats Sébastien la carte
maintenant elle est toute grise voilà la
carte est toute grise et c'est au
Québécois de la dessiner en fait les
Québécois ont dessiné la carte s'agit de
voir quelle couleur sera appliqué au
cours des prochaines heures et au fil
donc du dépouillement des votes cette
carte prendra des couleurs nous allons
tout au long de la soirée affichée vous
allez le voir arriver les logos des
partis avec le nombre de députés de
candidats pardonnez-moi élu ou en tête
chaque plqs pqpcq je le disais ça vaut
la peine qu'on le ressouling aux gens
qui nous écoutent c'est très rare et on
a eu un débat à 5 on le soulignait que
cinq parties sont en mesure de faire
élire des députés c'est cinq parties qui
sont compétitifs donc cinq parties il y
en a déjà eu mes cinq parties qui
peuvent prétendre aspirer à avoir un
siège à l'Assemblée nationale c'est très
rare même aux fédéral c'est pas le cas
parce que en général c'est une bataille
à 3 ou à 4 dépendamment des régions 5
c'est quand même 13 inhabituel est-ce
que cette dynamique là peut durer parce
que ça crée aussi un fragmentation du
vote de position qui pourrait favoriser
la caque on verra bien ce soir mais
c'est clair que ça fait une dynamique
très particulière ce soir dans les
résultats et ils ont aussi hâte que nous
les 810 candidats d'avoir les premiers
résultats oui il y a eu des sondages qui
montrait à peu près Chantal la même
chose n'empêche dans plusieurs régions
les sondages dans une circonscription ah
mais voilà on a déjà des résultats
extraordinaires la rapidité ce soir
premiers résultats dans Market ou Enrico
Chiconi le libéral le tir de l'arrière
mais vous voyez un bureau sur 157 market
les libéraux ne veulent pas laisser
échapper cette circonscription là on va
suivre ça dans le lois de Montréal l'île
aux Îles de la Madeleine Joël Arsenault
qui est en avance pour l'instant sur
Jonathan Lapierre le maire ça c'est un
combat de coq aux îles entre les deux ça
a été assez agressif comme campagne
électorale on verra six Joël Arsenault
maintient l'avance deux montagnes des
premiers résultats grosse grosse avance
ça c'est pas une surprise pour Benoît
charrette ministre l'environnement
698 il y a simplement 6 bureaux sur 165
alors ça dites vous que c'est
denjonquières c'est Yannick Gagnon qui
est en avance sur Caroline Dubé la
péquiste et troisième Isabelle champagne
du Parti conservateur
très forte avance encore une fois c'est
le vote par anticipation n'empêche une
Gava madame cire Denis Lamotte le caquis
qui le député sortant qui est un très
mince avance deux bureaux on va suivre
ça parce que ça ça peut être serré
madame
qu'on voit des résultats dans Rosemont
une avance pour la kakis sur Vincent
Marisol mais un bureau sur 186 donc
monsieur Marissal pour l'instant
la soirée jeune comme on dit je disais
Anne Gava lucioles peut-être ce soir
peut-être mais ça va dépendre du taux de
participation finale et malheureusement
ou heureusement dépendamment du point de
vue c'est pas une lutte à deux c'est une
lutte avec nos positions fragmentées
comme vous dites ici mais on verra alors
à un bureau de de une boîte là c'est
on a rien à dire pour l'instant encore
faut-il savoir où est-ce qu'elle est la
boîte
dans ce genre de circonscription là où
il y a des clivages géographiques
régionaux qui sont internes donc et
c'est le vote par anticipation les 15 20
premières minutes que vous allez voir
c'est le vote par anticipation ça vous
donne une idée de l'état de santé des
machines électorales ceux qui ont réussi
à faire voter leurs votes visiblement
c'est de la coalition à venir à Québec
qui d'après les sondages avait un vote
un peu plus âgé les 55 ans et plus qui
votent beaucoup par anticipation c'est
ce qu'on voit au fil de la soirée on va
voir les votes d'aujourd'hui entrée
public peut être un peu plus jeune
électeur un peu plus jeune ça pourrait
faire basculer certaines
circonscriptions on va aller voir
Sébastien le PLK on a une
circonscription en avance le PQ une QS
une ils sont à égalité chacun en ont une
pour l'instant ce début de résultat bon
mais sans surprise dans l'Ouest l'île de
Montréal ici quoi que dans cette
circonscription ici de market c'est
peut-être la surprise pour l'instant
avec cinq voies d'avance pour la
coalition de Québec soit super jeune
comme vous le dites heureusement ici ça
s'est promené au début entre partie de
Québec entre coalition Québec et Québec
solidaire mais c'est une circonscription
solidaire donc défendue par Vincent donc
ça commence à prendre non mais
tranquillement de la couleur alors bosse
Nord 1er résultat qu'on nous qu'on nous
donne je vous souligne que c'est un gros
départ oui c'est préliminaire mais gros
départ pour la CAQ partout en
pourcentage lutte provençal qui est en
avance sur le candidat Olivier Dumet
dont on parlait de des conservateurs
dans show Médée
monsieur Planet qui est en avant sur la
libérale ça c'était on disait si on
gardait dans Laval et libéraux ce sera
cheminée attendons voir n'empêche un
empêche ça sort et pour l'instant ça
sort très très fort pour la CAQ dans
saint François
Geneviève Hébert qui est en avance la
caquiste donc Saint-François qui
resterait kakis Mélissa généreux qui est
troisième mais un bureau donc on est
dans les 23 28 votes vous l'aurez
compris mais on vous les donne les îles
la Madeleine Jonathan Lapierre qui est
en avance sur joie l'arsenault donc là
je sens qu'on va en parler plusieurs
fois ils vont se croiser ça va finir au
ça va finir à la fin là
c'est un sur le goût regarde ça là 48%
ce qui est sorti il aime ce qu'il voit
être à sa place
ça donne une idée de tendance c'est vrai
que le vote par anticipation souvent ce
sont les électeurs plus âgés que c'est
une tranche d'électeurs qui a tendance à
être plus favorable à la coalition
Québec que d'autres tranches néanmoins
on aime toujours mieux fini commencer
comme ça
j'ai vu des soirées ou des gens qui
commençaient comme ça ont perdu mais je
pense pas que ce soit nécessairement que
ce soit ouais en tout cas il a partout
on a pas de résultats en outtawaï en
Mauricie sinon on a des résultats
partout dans les régions et le
pourcentage de la CAQ et très fort et
l'aval regardez Sébastien là-bas elle
est en train de se peinturer un peu en
bleu poudre de la coalition Québec femme
ici Sainte-Rose c'était déjà une
séquence qui leur appartenait show Médée
remarqué qu'avec 17% des votes si je
vois bien le tableau en ce moment le
Parti québécois n'est en avance dans
aucune circonscription malgré le 17 %
des votes c'est quand même ça pourrait
être un problème pour le Parti québécois
pour faire élire des députés ce choix il
y a un parti conservateur le voici celui
le chiffre 1 vous voyez conservateur
Christian Gauthier dans l'autre binaire
Frontenac qui est en avance sur Isabelle
Lecourt qui est la député sortante donc
savoir
déjà quand je vous dis que ça va aller
vite mesdames et messieurs dans Rousseau
réélu Louis Charles Thuin qui est élu
pour la deuxième fois donc je vous
rappelle que monsieur Legault a déjà été
il est dans l'Assomption mais déjà été
député d'un ruisseau dans sa première
ville dans une autre incarnation police
quand Bernard Landry était allé le
chercher pour faire de la politique
les deux
regardez la carte Sébastien je tiens
votre attention sur le binaire Frontenac
ici ou le Parti conservateur est en
avance par 40 petites voix seulement
trois boîtes évidemment de scrutin de
dépouiller on surveillait surtout beau
ce Nord beau Sud mais pour l'instant
Boston ça tient pour le colissium avenir
Québec et
d'abord Sud aussi le pcq est deuxième on
va voir que c'est la lutte des poulets
juste pour voir dans beau Sud ils sont
les trois en première position mais
c'est Samuel de la coalition Québec qui
est en avance pour l'instant donc ce
sera une région qu'on surveiller
beaucoup ce soir la région de labo
habituellement dans chaudière à palache
le Parti conservateur récolte 39% des
intentions de vote laquelle le Québec
intentions
elle récolte officiellement 38 % des
votes ce soir la coalition de Québec est
à 45 c'est quand même donc très serré là
ça veut dire que plusieurs
circonscriptions de cette région là
arrive sud de Québec vont être
surveiller toute la soirée alors
d'autres résultats aux jeux de la
Madeleine on disait ça va se recroiser
Joël Arsenault qui est en avance sur
Jonathan Lapierre maintenant de
186 voix il y a 18 bureaux quand même ça
commence à être significatif sur 53 à
suivre donc aux îles mais Joël Arsenault
qui pourrait et ça ailleurs c'est le
seul et qui ce qui est en avance pour
l'instant c'est aux îles et on n'a pas
de résultats je crois dans Matane
matapedia pour l'instant avoir n'a pas
encore
Saint-François Geneviève Hébert qui
garde sa position de tête qui est la
député sortante dans saint François
ça c'était un espoir de Québec solitaire
qui est loin pour l'instant dans market
5 petites voix on a que deux bureaux de
dépouiller Enrico chiconique qui traîne
l'arrière ça on va le surveiller parce
que c'est Ville Lasalle l'Ouest les
libéraux dit à la fin on a on croit
avoir gardé ce comté Sainte Marie Saint
Jacques Manon Macé qui est avec un
bureau en avance c'est très préliminaire
alors vous le voyez c'est un gros gros
gros coup gros départ pour la CAQ ça
rentre rapidement déjà 25
circonscriptions ils sont en avance ou
sur le point de les prendre donc c'est
un départ canon pour la coalition à
Québec
[Musique]
Radio-Canada prévoit que le prochain
gouvernement sera dirigé par la
Coalition avenir Québec François Legault
qui sera majoritaire
20h10 Radio-Canada prévoit un
gouvernement de la CAQ majoritaire
monsieur Legault qui a donc on voit des
images du rassemblement à Québec gagné
son pari les beaucoup de gens qu'on
verra comment tout ça va se traduire
dans toutes les régions du Québec ont un
peu dit vous avez pas eu un vrai mandat
continuez pour reprendre son slogan
parce que il y a eu la pandémie qui vous
a enlevé deux ans il a redessiné la
carte politique du Québec il va
continuer à le faire avec son
nationalisme sans rupture Véronique vous
êtes au rassemblement c'est
évidemment la joie même qu'on s'y attend
c'est une joie et on doit être très
content des chiffres des pourcentages
moi je ne vous entends pas
allez-y
là je vous entends un peu mieux allez je
vais
vous montrer si ça commence à se
rappeler alors ce sont principalement
des employés pour l'instant de la
coalition à venir Québec on sait que la
CAQ a tout près de 400 employés et on
leur a demandé de venir ici de venir
encourager de venir avec les bénévoles
et les candidats commencent à arriver
tranquillement pas vite j'ai vu
Geneviève Ribeau Jonathan Julien et on
voit qu'ils sont de bonne humeur avec
les résultats préliminaires c'est sûr
qu'ils ont encore quelques inquiétudes
là pour des compter ou le vote
conservateur peut peut-être venir
brouiller les cartes mais quand même
jusqu'à maintenant là vous voyez que
c'est la bonne humeur qui règne ici
on les comprend avec les chiffres qu'ils
ont devant les yeux il est à écouter ce
n'est pas des blagues il est à 52%
actuellement mais il y a des régions je
le répète ça va ce pourcentage là risque
de fléchir n'empêche c'est énorme énorme
comme départ tour de table sur ce sur
cette formation du gouvernement
Luc je commence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a gagné son pari les Québécois il dit ce
soir vous continuez je suis en train de
manger de mots parce qu'il y a quand
même été deux ans et demi en pandémie
ils disent bien continuez
c'était prévisible mais là il faut
s'inquiéter un peu de position moi je
suis un peu peur et malgré que ce soit
très fragmentaire c'est très fort pour
laquelle très fort c'est très fort et
Sébastien juste un tour de cartes et
ensuite avec les Chantal je vais vous
donner la parole mais voyons voir à quoi
ça ressemble passons région de Montréal
allons dans la région de Québec il y en
a deux il y en a le Parti québécois
viennent perdre Jonquières en passant
c'est Yannick Gagnon c'est un gain de
Québec solidaire donc le Parti québécois
est rayé de la carte
oui qu'est-ce que j'ai dit de la CAQ et
dans les gens québécon surveillait les
circonscriptions de Chauveau
actuellement la coalition Québec est en
avance de 212 voies et rids se présente
le chef du Parti conservateur dans cette
circonscription on surveillait aussi sur
la rive-sud de Québec la chaudière à
palache beau snowbo-sud pour l'instant
ça tient pour la CAQ on est sûrement une
grosse avance mais ça tient plus grosse
avance ici dans beau Sud pour la Québec
c'est un espoir pour l'instant au moment
où on se parle pour le Parti
conservateur c'est dans le binaire
Frontenac sans surprise monsieur Legault
dans l'Assomption qui est réélu dans sa
circonscription avec une écrasante
majorité évidemment monsieur Legault qui
arrive arrivera à l'Assemblée nationale
avec un grand contingent comment ça va
finir on sait pas mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que ça a commencé comme il le
souhaitait la cape du son du
rassemblement de la CAQ applaudissent la
victoire de leur chef
proche des gens alors Sébastien Tournier
de cartes oui non une petite surprise au
moment où on se parle dans Du Plessis
mais un une voix d'avance la coalition à
venir Québec ici à des espoirs de faire
ce game et craignait un effet Rambo un
effet mesure sanitaire c'est la région
de Sept-Îles notamment ici tiens c'est
intéressant dans un évêque deux points
d'avance deux votes d'avance seulement
pour les candidate du Parti conservateur
donc ils sont compétitifs c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre dans ces
circonscriptions et nous allons voir
vous voulez qu'on aille voir la bouche
monsieur Labeau c'est étonnant c'était
étonnant ok alors allons-y ah ben oui le
binaire frontière ça vient de retourner
en faveur de la coalition Québec avec 87
voix bosnord qui surveillait 38 d'avance
et près de 700 voix pour d'embauche Sud
mais le PQ est deuxième dans toutes ces
circonscriptions très bien faut se
rappeler Patrice que François Legault a
un vent en face pendant une bonne partie
de la campagne électorale mais il
partait avec un très fort vent de 59%
des Québécois étaient satisfaits du
gouvernement taux rarement vu pour un
gouvernement sortant il y a eu la
pandémie les gens se sont dit et pas pu
probablement aller au bout de ce qu'il
voulait il y a bien gérer ça dans un
seul grand taux de satisfaction oui il y
a eu des mécontents mais en général les
gens étaient plutôt satisfaits alors il
y a pas eu malgré tous les dérapages de
la campagne il y a pas eu d'événements
secousses susceptibles de secouer le 59
% de toute satisfaction c'est ce qui
fait qu'on a un gouvernement majoritaire
de la coalition Québec ce soir
mais le début de soirée le plus
difficile selon moi c'est Québec
solidaire l'objectif de position
officielle ça s'en va pas là pourcentage
de votes jusqu'à présent le PQ
est plus élevé dans le pourcentage de
votes ces deux objectifs ou et on peut
se demander en regardant de la
circonscription heureusement par exemple
si l'espèce de succès d'estime du PQ va
pas finir par coûter des plumes à Québec
solidaires des gens qui sont tournés à
la maison dans des circonscriptions
QS
qui comme on le fait
des fois Marie-Victorin il y a eu un
match récemment avec une partiel madame
dorismond qui est l'avait remporté pour
laque elle est en confortable avant
quand même d'aller voir le tableau même
si on parle que de Siri
266 voies de plus alors on va justement
on a on a une entrevue avec
Geneviève Guilbaud très bien allons-y
Véronique vous êtes avec Geneviève
Guilbaud
sortante
alors votre première réaction c'est des
résultats préliminaires mais vous
prédisez combien de visiter par exemple
à la coalition je réponds à mesure de
donner un nom nous on a dit on aimerait
bien conserver les 76 qu'on avait déjà
puis faire des gains entre autres des
gains ici dans notre capitale nationale
là on vient de voir que notre député
sorta de Chauveau est en avance et sans
probablement gagner chevaux ce soir ça
c'est un souci qu'on avait parce qu'il y
a Monsieur James présentait là et là on
va garder chaud pour probablement
j'aimerais bien qu'on gagne Jean Le Sage
aussi il y a un certain nombre
d'endroits comme ça au Québec Sherbrooke
Maurice Richard à Montréal on a des
espoirs aussi une excellente candidate
Audrey donc c'est très très excitant ce
qui est pas en train de se passer en ce
moment puis je veux vraiment remercier
les Québécois puis remercier mes 124
collègues qui ont été députés un peu
partout au Québec pendant cette campagne
là qui est difficile toujours pour tout
le monde une campagne ce soir c'est le
verdict final et donc on est heureux
merci bonne soirée
très bien oui ben évidemment que la vis
première ministre est contente on a on
verra on n'a pas eu les résultats dans
les vies je crois dans chute de la
chaudière non plus on va et on a
d'autres résultats dans saint François
Mélissa généreux et qu'es quand Chantal
disait que c'est une soirée qui commence
difficilement on verra comment ça se
termine pendant qu'on nous amène des
résultats dans les vies Bernard
drinville qui était en forte forte
avance c'est pas nécessairement étonnant
mais vous voyez les chiffres parlent de
même 17 sur 1985 c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal terminé dans son cas
Charlevoix côte de Beaupré
Karine Bourassa qui est qui est en qui
est en tête sur Myriam Fortin que est-ce
qui est en deuxième place là dessus
Saint-François donc Mélissa généreux
QS je le disais avait beaucoup d'espoir
pour le docteur généreux elle est en
deuxième elle traîne l'arrière 6 bureaux
sur 205 quand même une avance
significative pour Geneviève Hébert qui
veut un deuxième mandat dans Du Plessis
une seule voix ça ça il y a moins de
votes alors ça peut être très serré très
longtemps mais c'est le Québec solidaire
madame Mestro cochon qui est en avance
d'une seule petite voix
mais vous avez quatre bureaux sur 158 on
a peu de bureau mais Jonquières 18
bureaux sur 160 Yannick gagne non ça
c'est un gain il a été déclaré gagnant
il a circonscription de Sylvain
Gaudreault que le PQ Perse c'est des
morceaux qui partent d'histoire pour le
PQ je mets au Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean on
n'avait pas eu de députés pékistes
depuis 1973 donc à moins d'une vraie
véritable surprise dans une autre
séquons étant le meilleur espoir quand
même du PQ ça veut dire que pour la
première fois depuis 50 ans il y aura
pas de députés pékistan
ça c'est un Jonquière donc on est très
content du côté de la coalition du
Québec on est on s'est emparé de tout ce
de tout ce territoire là regardez le
Parti québécois la seule circonscription
est-ce qu'on a déjà des des résultats
dans Matane m'a tapédia alors voir si on
a des résultats dans Madame metapedia
mais je pense qu'on en a pas beaucoup de
circonscriptions aussi pour de Québec
solidaire pour lesquels on n'a pas
beaucoup de résultats pour l'instant ce
qui explique pourquoi
QS est à 3
circonscriptions en avance pour
l'instant
très bien alors Bernard drinville je
disais c'était une formalité monsieur
Draveil qui fait son qui refait son
entrée à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
vies on essaiera de lui parler un peu
plus tard tout à l'heure alors est-ce
que il deviendra monsieur 3e lien c'est
à voir lui on a beaucoup parlé de lui
aussi dans la fin de cette campagne
électorale pas pour les bonnes raisons
j'en voulais qui est réélu dans Trois
Rivières monsieur boulet donc
qui s'est disqualifié avait dit à votre
émission avec sera plus ministre
élu pour les libéraux les libéraux qui
en ont 13 élus en avance pour l'instant
on est très en fait tous sont très très
loin de leur score le PQ il y en a deux
peut-être c'est des premiers résultats
on verra que c'est le DR4 d'un Rosemont
on nous dit que Québec Solidaire a
repris l'avance dans Chauveau Sylvain
Lévesque qui est en avance sur Eric dum
monsieur Duhem qui est deuxième mais qui
est néanmoins deuxième a offert une
tournée des chefs si vous le voulez bien
on le disait il y avait trois des cinq
chefs qui étaient dont le l'avenir est
incertain monsieur Gabriel ado Dubois un
seul bureau mais qui est en avance dans
le coin lui c'est ça devrait bien aller
ce soir dans Gouin pour Gabriel ado
Dubois
très bien alors allons voir la région de
Montréal analysons donc commençons par
la balle qui est en train de se
peinturer Bleu Poudre regardez ce que ça
donnait en 2018 c'était pas mal plus
rouge Laval donc dans la circonscription
ici de femmes c'est construction de 1000
aussi le parti de la coalition Québec
espère peut-être faire un gage je veux
juste vous montrer ce qui se passe à
Montréal il y a une bataille dans les
coins
Maurice Richard ici ça c'est important
Québec Solidaire est en avance par 40
voix mais ça joue dur ils ont un
candidat vedette harunoisy contre Audrey
Murray de la Coalition avenir Québec
donc c'est une bataille qu'on va suivre
ça ce soir parce que c'est un gain pour
eux important au détriment des libéraux
exactement les libéraux avaient fait
lire Marie Montpellier qui ne s'est pas
représenté pour à ces élections aussi et
c'est peut-être l'heure candidat sur
lequel misait le plus
président de la Banque de développement
du Canada dans market je vois votre dans
le coin rouge je vois qu'il a repris
l'avance tu connais repris l'avance dans
à côté Marguerite Bourgeois les libéraux
tiennent le coup aussi et on n'a pas
encore de résultats ici ça Henri
Sainte-Anne ou la Verdun de
circonscription qu'on surveille
particulièrement aussi ce soir
on la comprend alors oui il y a des
coins aussi beaucoup plus lents que
d'autres mais voyez le pourcentage
51% c'est énorme compte tenu de que dans
la partie il y a cinq parties politiques
pour l'instant c'est énorme alors on
attendait des votes dans l'outawa le
pourcentage va fluctuer mais c'est un
départ extrêmement fort pour laque dans
bouche-nord par exemple ou la cafetière
le coût avec Luc provençal qui brille un
troisième mandat pour la taxe Olivier
Dumet qui est pas loin là c'est ils sont
deuxièmes il y a 13 circonscriptions au
Québec où le pcq est deuxième en ce
moment bon
Saint Louis les libéraux avec Jenifer
macaron est en avance même si très
fragmentaire on serait très surpris du
contraire dans Louis Hébert genevièvebo
à qui on a parlé il y a quelques minutes
étant avance à Québec également
notre binaire Frontenac des
circonscriptions vous le voyez où le
parti conservateur est deuxième là
Isabelle Lecourt qui brille deuxième
mandat madame Lecourt dans l'autre
binaire Frontenac donc ils ont repris la
tête mais les deuxièmes c'est le parti
conservateur parier que Monsieur Jam ce
soir va beaucoup parler de ce statut de
deuxième dans plein d'endroit
circonscription en ce moment ce sera
intéressant dans l'île de Morin sur
l'île de Montréal aussi dans les
communautés les circonscriptions un peu
plus anglophones vous demandiez des
résultats Patrice pour l'Est du Québec
on en a un stock un premier résultat
pour Matane matapedia il y aura pas
d'histoire ici Pascal berbé va être élu
sans histoire et regardez ce qui se
passe ici bonne aventure par exemple
c'est préliminaires évidemment mais le
Parti québécois a un candidat vedette
Alexis Deschênes pour l'instant en léger
recul sur la candidate de la coalition
Québec
Gaspé qui est aussi une circonscription
du Parti québécois ici ça a l'air un peu
moins serré en tout cas au départ avec
Stéphane Sainte-Croix qui mène sur la
députée sortante Mégane Mélenchon et si
j'arrive à vous trouver les îles oui
elles sont ici les îles c'est le
deuxième pour le PQ voilà c'est la
deuxième circonscription en effet ou le
PQ est en avance Joël Arsenault mais ça
c'est pas encore bouger les madelino ne
sont pas fidèles les changent parfois de
pendant que les gens peuvent voir le
chiffre de 63 on a déjà depuis un
certain temps parler d'un gouvernement
majoritaire ben vous voyez ils sont déjà
à 63 puis il est quoi et quelle heure
est-il 20h26 c'est très très rapide
comme début de soirée électorale on a vu
d'autres et rapides oui c'est rapide le
bon le pourcentage va bouger un peu à
force que les votes d'aujourd'hui
rentrent votre parenticipation
visiblement été très fort envers laka
qu'on s'y attendait mais ça reste un
départ rapide à 51%, les sondages
étaient plutôt autour de 38 42
dépendamment la fourchette ça va baisser
un peu mais pour l'instant je pense que
du côté de François Legault on doit être
particulièrement heureux La Pinière les
libéraux garderaient j'ai vu sur la
Rive-Sud
à côté on n'est pas encore de résultats
pour la première c'est ça ah oui c'est
juste c'est mon doigt qui est trop gros
ça c'est la porte La Pinière la prairie
ça devient mélangeant mais il y aura pas
de résultats dans La Pinière pour
l'instant
très bien il y a des gens qui vont faire
leur entrée à l'Assemblée nationale des
nouveaux venus dans Bertrand elle est en
bonne posture France Hélène duranchot
elle n'est pas élue mais elle est
largement en avance ça c'est les
Laurentides Bertrand France Hélène
Duranceau que beaucoup de gens en tout
cas des gens de la CAQ et peut-être en
premier lieu monsieur Lego voyait voit
déjà comme ministre dans bonne aventure
Catherine Blouin qui est en avance sur
Alexis Deschênes elle serait une
nouvelle venue elle aussi ça serait un
gain dans ce cas là sur le Parti
québécois chute de la chaudière martine
Biron qui est en avance ça avait été une
des plus grosses majorités en 2018 pour
la carte c'est un des premiers compter à
des kystes à l'époque qui est devenu
kakistan suite c'est un terreau très
très fertile pour la coalition Québec
évidemment aussi pour le Parti
conservateur du Québec mais surtout pour
la CAQ ça ça va être un baume si jamais
ça se confirme pour Québec solidaire
monsieur Boisy a une boisée qui est
en avance dans Maurice Richard alors à
suivre et justement Valérie Gamache est
avec quelqu'un dans Montréal Outremont
Michel 7 lakoué qui est en avance ça
évidemment vous êtes la coin quand je
disais des nouveaux venus à l'Assemblée
nationale elle en fera partie Valérie
vous êtes avec Amir Cadière qui doit pas
être très heureux du début de soirée
merci
pour Québec solidaire de 2008 à 2018
comment vous vous analysez ces premiers
résultats de la soirée pour Québec
solidaire c'est sûr que pour moi c'est
toujours exaltant le seul fait qu'on
parle de nos de notre partie sur la
scène québécoise nous avons tant
espéré ce jour-là c'est-à-dire un parti
qui arrive peu à peu c'est peut-être pas
tout à fait fait à maturité qui a la
confiance de plus en plus de gens
maintenant moi je suis assez confiant
pour la soirée je suis sûr qu'on va
faire des gains et quel je ne peux pas
dire avec assurance mais c'est sûr que
quel que soit le résultat à la fin de la
soirée Québec solidaire s'impose quand
même comme la voix de l'opposition
principale si c'est pas l'opposition
officielle c'est quand même la position
la plus combative
à ce moment c'est j'espère que non mais
bon faut quand même entrevoir toutes les
possibilités il y a les lourdeurs
historiques de ce que c'est le Québec et
disons le fait que nous avons encore du
chemin à faire pour conquérir le pouvoir
entre ce moment et le jour au Québec
solidaire prétend 2026 assurant le
pouvoir il y a un chemin à faire est-ce
que on sera les positions officielle je
l'espère mais l'opposition véritable
celle qui est capable de mener le combat
avec monsieur Legault je pense tout le
monde a reconnu bel et bien québéculé
pour vous c'est possible on a vu qu'il
est temps en avance là oui absolument
Maurice Richard j'ai très fort espoir
c'est le cas aussi de Verdun j'espère
qu'on aura des surprises dans bio dans
un ressentant dans Saint-François alors
j'ai hâte comme vous de voir les
résultats merci beaucoup monsieur caser
alors voilà Patrice
merci merci beaucoup oui mais monsieur
cadire on le voyait quand même dans le
ton respirer un départ autre pour Québec
solidaire un petit peu plus canon
certainement
des raisons s'inquiéter d'autres parts
ça prend de lancer pour se rendre à
l'opposition officielle le
fond de
commerce du Parti libéral sur l'île de
Montréal ça lui donnait une longueur
d'avance pas de la rattraper ça prend
probablement un peu plus d'élan que ce
qu'on voit depuis le début du décompte
on verra Sherbrooke amenez-nous à
Sherbrooke Sébastien c'est intéressant
parce que c'est une lutte entre une
vedette la carte qui voulait ravir là
c'est chaud là et dans cet océan de bleu
poudre Sherbrooke ici c'est toujours le
Québec solidaire qui est en avance avec
la députée sortante Christine Labrie
très légère avance avec 10 boîtes de
scrutin dépouillées sur Caroline
St-Hilaire une candidate vedette on
surveillait roineranda
ou aussi Québec solidaire souhaite
conserver cette circonscription mais
regardez pour l'instant c'est la
coalition à Québec est en avance avec 65
boîtes de plus deux boîtes de scrutin
dépouillés sur 166 mais n'empêche
n'empêche madame cire surveiller
beaucoup ses circonscriptions dans GABA
pour l'instant c'est la coalition à
venir Québec qui est en avance avec 87
voix et regardez cette image arrêt sur
image quand ça parle beaucoup là
c'était comme ça avant là on voit un peu
plus de bleu de bleu poudre 10% pour
Québec solidaire c'est vraiment pas fort
jusqu'à maintenant 10% des votes
exprimés on doit pas être content chez
eux égalité avec le Parti conservateur
du Québec pour l'instant n'est pas en
avance aucune circonscription le Parti
québécois c'est les îles et m'attendent
matapedia donc c'est vraiment les deux
les
îles c'est très serré donc le scénario
d'un seul est encore possible
malheureusement pour les piquets c'est
Québec solidaire à 7 ils sont loin du
compte les libéraux aussi là ils
divisent par deux et plus ce qu'ils
avaient avant donc oui ils sont
l'opposition officielle mais pour
l'instant manque beaucoup beaucoup de
votes sur l'île de Montréal
est vraiment le plus lent alors ça va
bouger pour les libéraux ça va bouger
pour Québec solidaire encore c'est
vraiment l'île de Montréal hier au
Québec ça sort assez rapidement l'île de
Montréal pour l'instant est en retard
dans le décompte très bien Sonia le
appelle à parler il y a quelques
secondes on s'envolait
merci à tous les citoyens de la
confiance
[Applaudissements]
merci des citoyens de la confiance alors
voilà une soirée qui ressemble à celle
de Dark Ford qui je crois viens envoyer
quelques mots à monsieur Legault
traduction libre je suis très excité que
mon ami le Premier ministre François
Legault reçoit un autre mandat fort des
électeurs du Québec on va continuer à
construire des liens profonds avec les
deux provinces et
renforcer les liens économiques qu'il y
a pour créer des bonnes Jobs payantes ça
ça va faire plaisir monsieur Lego et
surtout félicitations mon ami
félicitations
ce qui prend des cours actifs de
français monsieur
chouchou Laval on va aller faire un
petit truc des résultats
d'un Fabre la kakis qui est en voie de
de remporter ces préliminaires n'empêche
c'est une bonne avance Alice Abou Khalil
Laval des rapides madame Ethan qui est
en avance sur Sao Paulo qui était le
seul qui se représentait pour les
libéraux à Laval tous les autres avaient
quitté ça conscription au baromètre des
rapides très rare qu'il va du mauvais
côté mille Julie Saïd qui est en avance
également sur la candidate libérale
Francine Charbonneau qui se représentait
pas pour les libéraux et dans cheminée
comme prévu comme prévu la candidate
libérale tient le fort pour l'instant
donc il en reste une Sébastien voilà et
c'est ici avec le contraste avec 2018 et
frappant quand on regarde à quel point
le Parti libéral était présent donc on
voit des images de monsieur Legault qui
est avec Madame braise on épouse qui
écoute la soirée
et avec ces deux garçons Xavier et
Victor sur le groupe qui est tout
sourire on ne serait à moins
qui il faut le dire on l'a pas mal dit
pendant tout au long de la campagne qui
a trouvé des bouts difficiles de cette
campagne électorale qui semblait dire
pourquoi on s'acharne imposer certaines
questions sur le troisième lien sur
l'immigration sur différents dossiers
il a
ce qu'il voulait ce soir totalement on
va probablement pas embrasser sa sœur ce
soir le premier on va faire attention
la dernière fois il y avait eu tellement
d'enthousiasme qui s'était précipité
mais là je pense qu'on va faire
attention deuxième fois on fera pas
l'erreur
très bien alors oui il part avec on
verra jusqu'où ça va aller si ça si ça
se maintenait là on a des résultats dans
105 circonscriptions sur 125 donc ça va
encore bouger les chiffres que vous
voyez mais
de toute façon allons à Québec solidaire
[Applaudissements]
matapedia donc le Parti québécois qui
prenait ça on a trois élus en avance le
seul élu c'est monsieur Bérubé c'était
écrit dans le ciel monsieur Bérubé Alain
s'il n'en restait qu'un seul être lui
debout fort et effectivement très fort
dans sa circonscription Sébastien et à
Québec il y a une petite histoire qui
s'écrit peut-être tâchereau ici c'est le
parti de Québec solidaire qui est en
avance assez confortable avec 300 voix
d'avance mais juste à côté genre c'est
la circonscription du député seul
Zanetti le député sortant pour l'instant
il tient de l'arrière mais il y a 7
boîtes de scrutin d'appuyées sur
161 Juifs je vous ai amener sur l'île de
Montréal parce que il y a deux
circonscriptions du coup dernière
nouvelle quand j'avais vérifié qui nous
intéresse peut-être particulièrement
Anjou Louis riez conscription libérale
pour l'instant c'est la coalition Québec
qui est en avance et Maurice Richard ici
l'avance des des solidaires et de 140
voix sur les kakis c'était une
circonscription libérale mais Marie
montre petit la député sur tente ne sait
pas représente très bien donc à suivre
il y a des luttes et je rappelle aux
gens ce qui se posent la question et la
chef libérale on n'a pas de résultats
danser Henri Sainte-Anne plus que dans
Camille Laurent ici que la
circonscription de Paul Saint-Pierre
plein monde et Rosemont Québec solidaire
on le voit sur le Lille a repris
l'avance 342 voix d'avance pour Vincent
maréchal sur la coalition à venir Québec
avec 24 boîtes de scrutin depuis très
bien donc
luxe on verra comment ça va se terminer
mais Québec solidaire espérait
évidemment mieux oui mais il faut dire
que on a rien dans Mercier là qui est le
Plateau Mont-Royal on a rien dans dans
Verdun ou j'espère faire des gains mais
par contre la roue de Boissy je dois
dire que ça moi j'aurais parié sur
Audrey
Audrey gestionnaire pour parce que c'est
un parti c'est un quartier qui est pas
totalement urbain le c'est un quartier
qui est à
cheval sur une partie d'urbanité puis
une partie de de quartier plutôt
banlieusard de Dan cycle du Nord à round
Boisy responsable que demander une
commission contre le racisme systémique
qui a été au premier plan pour la lutte
pour la laïcité mais
débattant contre la loi 21 donc
quelqu'un qui est très très marqué très
bien dans la lutte contre le racisme ça
va être quelqu'un qui très vocal en
chambre si jamais il apparaît alors on
verra si ils atteindront le disque
qu'ils avaient Québec solidaire on parle
de Mercier où il y a pas encore de
résultats Émilie et Christian
commentaire sur cette victoire qui
s'annonce quand même forte et décisive
de la carte Émilie
mais c'est sûr que c'est pas surprenant
ce qu'on voit en ce moment
la bataille ce soir c'était vraiment
pour essentiellement pour savoir de qui
va être composé le position et puis
comme on le disait un peu un peu juste
un peu plus tôt il y a beaucoup de comté
pivot à Montréal qui sont pas encore
déterminés la seule chose qu'on voit
vraiment pour l'instant qui est pas sur
qui est une nouvelle information c'est
la carte c'est la carte de Laval où on
voit que la CAQ est en train vraiment de
faire des gains donc pour ne serait-ce
que pour les pertes à Laval qui sont pas
bien confirmés mais qui ont de l'air à
se confirmer ça semble être une très
mauvaise soirée pour le parti libérale à
ce niveau là et en fait plus de gens une
bonne soirée à part monsieur le Gaulle
disons-le franchement Christian les
conservateurs qui sont deuxième dans
plein de circonscriptions je n'arrive
pas à percer là il y a toujours une
surprise de ce soir de l'élection c'est
une énorme surprise puis elle vient pas
du côté du tout on l'attendait dans une
démocratie parlementaire de type Brit
avec un parti qui récolte 50% des voix
c'est énorme donc c'est une grosse
légitimité pour le gouvernement logo moi
je l'attribue à deux choses évidemment
sa gestion de la pandémie parce que
c'était valeureux même ceux des gens qui
ont été critiques pour un autre élément
dans les commentateurs par le passé je
trouve les supposés gaffes en matière
d'immigration c'est clair qu'il y en a
eu deux le constellation la violence
puis le dérapage de son ministre de
l'immigration mais pour le reste quand
c'est un manifester son inquiétude pour
l'immigration je pense qu'il s'adresse
au Québec profond c'est-à-dire c'est bon
commentateur il s'adressait au Québec
francophone profond et moi je vois un
lien avec le 50% actuellement pour le
reste le PQ sans me sauver
quelle que soit le nombre des députés ce
qui est énorme aussi on va voir iridium
c'est clair que s'il y a pas de député
c'est un gros problème puis le perdant
tout le monde le dit c'est Québec
solidaire parce que c'était jusqu'à
présent le parti nouveau le parti des
jeunes qui se posait en options et c'est
la confirmation que les élections sont
toujours en partie faite de choses qui
n'étaient pas prévues moi le 50% de la
CAQ je suis renvoyé ça risque de bouger
le corps mais vous avez raison de
souligner que c'est très élevé comme
pourcentage très bien Émilie je vous je
vous laisse aller vous devez aller à nos
collègues anglais on se retrouve à la
première résultats pour devenir anglaise
les voici dans saint Henri Sainte-Anne
20 voies de plus sur l'avocat Guillaume
Cliche Rivard avocat spécialisé en
immigration qui
qui voulait espérer remporter Saint
Henri Sainte-Anne à avoir mais un bureau
on va se on va se garder d'allonger de
longues analyses là dessus
et on s'en va à nottaway voir des
résultats dans Gatineau Robert Bussière
qui tente de se faire élire et c'est
bien parti pour une deuxième fois donc
c'était une prise de la 4 la dernière
fois en Outaouais et ça semble se
confirmer dans Pontiac mais le sang
surprise
André Fortin ça s'est jamais été dans
une liste de circonscriptions en danger
monsieur Fortin qui qui va être élu dans
quelques minutes
si la tendance se maintient martine
Biron notre ancienne collègue qui est
élu dans chute de la chaudière donc
Madame Biron qui va faire son entrée à
l'Assemblée nationale
voilà elle avait fait le d'ailleurs elle
voulait annoncé Sébastien comme chef de
bureau ça a été un petit choc pour vous
l'aviez dit et depuis je l'appelle
madame Biron non non je blague je
l'appelle Martine quand même
félicitations d'avoir été élu juste
peut-être un petit mot sur l'outawa vous
en avez parlé le résultat qu'on attend
c'est celui de all mais malheureusement
pour l'instant on n'a pas de résultats
dans all une autre série en tout cas en
théorie on verra ce que ça donne ce soir
la CAQ actuellement c'est pour vous
illustrer avec des chiffres très simples
cette montée gagne 12 % de pourcentage
les libéraux en perte 12 donc c'est
énorme c'est vraiment dans les
pourcentages c'est énorme et ça explique
pourquoi monsieur Legault même si sa
langue doit être mordurée à passer la
campagne à ne pas parler en mal de
Justin Trudeau parce que les électeurs
qui l'avaient besoin d'aller chercher le
parti large le plus faible devant lui
c'est des électeurs j'avais voté Trudeau
il y a un an donc
et c'est vraiment retenu il y a eu
plusieurs
occasions au débat dans des points de
presse il y a un an il n'avait que de
parole sur Justin Trudeau et la menace à
la nation mais c'est une stratégie qui
certainement va payer ce soir en tout
cas c'est très payant pour l'instant
c'est très payant pour l'instant
évidemment qu'on va avoir des résultats
dans certaines circonscriptions qu'on
attend avec impatience vous voyez que
avec solidaire remonte on est rendu à 8
donc ça va être intéressant mais la
majorité de la coalition du Québec elle
est franche et les fortes des sondages
pour l'instant se sont pas trompés mais
il reste encore des batailles locales
intéressantes à suivre les sondages sont
un peu trompés
on verra effectivement plus 12 plus 12
pour la 4 - 12 pour les libéraux -5 pour
Québec solidaire moins 3 pour le Parti
québécois et plus neuf alors il y a tu
gagnes évidemment il partait à moins de
deux là dissolution
c'était à un point 5
réaction du maire de Québec avec une
pointe du monde Bruno marchand
voix d'amour sur Twitter j'ai entendu un
peu avant de féliciter le nouveau
Premier ministre François Hugo on ne
sait jamais sourire en coin ce sera un
plaisir de travailler à nouveau avec
vous pour notre capital national
félicitations à tous les élus et tous
les candidats pour cette élections il y
a un dossier litigieux qui s'en est
entre les deux là le troisième bien mais
c'était une référence évidemment à son
élection à lui à Monsieur marchand on va
ouvrir une petite parenthèse mesdames et
messieurs troisième mien ne vous
inquiétez pas on repart pas là-dessus
pendant toutes les missions mais le
maire de Québec nous a dit qu'on était à
Québec en émission spéciale
que il était incontournable dans la
prise de décision que si lui n'était pas
d'accord avec le projet qui va être
présenté ça se fera pas etes-vous
d'accord avec vous non c'est pas de la
façon de gouverner de la CAQ ils
prennent les décisions ils ont
bien changé je pense pas très peu
d'écart pour les élus municipaux je vais
vous dire que je le pense alors s'ils
veulent le troisième lien même si
Monsieur marchand n'est pas d'accord ils
le font très bien
c'est pas toujours évident
appel à la collaboration de Valérie
plante nous avons un félicitations à
François Legault et son équipe nous
avons hâte de poursuivre le travail pour
répondre aux priorité des Montréal et
montréalaises et des municipalités la
transition écologique l'habitation la
mobilité et la sécurité ce sont les
sujets qu'elle met au jeu
très bien alors madame plante qui elle
aussi à rencontrer tous les candidats
donc monsieur Legault et elle a beaucoup
de demandes Camille Laurin premier
résultat pour Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon Richard Campo qui est le député
sortant est en avance un seul bureau sur
173 là vraiment les les tous les
pékistes doivent avoir les yeux rivés
sur Camille Laurin pour la prochaine
heure parce que ça ça peut faire mal si
il arrivait deuxième il n'arrivait pas à
se faire élire monsieur Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon je rappelle que
pour l'instant en particulier
mais pour l'instant en particulier il y
a les yeux de la Madeleine en avance et
il y a Matane matapedia c'est tout après
Geneviève Guilbaud relu on va passer les
ministres du cabinet logo réélu
Mathieu Lacombe en Outaouais réélu qui
était ministre de la Famille c'est des
larges majorités Rick Girard le ministre
des Finances réélu lui il a presque reçu
un avis qu'il allait rester au finance
mais pas aussi clair que dans le cas de
Monsieur Dubé François bonardel ministre
des Transports réélu
et Rosemont ben voilà Monsieur Marisa
qui a repris une nette avance sur la
candidate kakiste dans Rosemont et
Sébastien Desrosiers vous êtes donc au
rassemblement à Boucherville avec le
candidat du Parti québécois justement
dans Rosemont
exactement le comédien Pierre-Luc
Brillant bonsoir Monsieur brillant
bonsoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
résultats à ce moment-ci québécois est
en avance dans deux circonscriptions
est-ce que vous attendiez à être en
meilleure posture à ce moment-ci
les résultats sont très parcellents
encore il y a plusieurs circonscriptions
dont on se demande encore ce qui peut se
passer mais je pense que ce qui est le
plus intéressant ici c'est de regarder
le suffrage universel ou le Parti
québécois est nettement au dessus des
autres parties qui font pas qu'ils
seront qui formeront pas le gouvernement
je pense que c'est à ça qu'il faut
s'intéresser beaucoup puis ça nous en
dit long aussi sur notre mode de scrutin
en ce moment je pense que là il était
avec deux possibles
circonscriptions avec plus de de vote
que toutes les autres parties il y a une
question à se poser mais on se la posera
après l'élection et la question se
posera effectivement vous êtes bon en
retard sur le candidat solidaire dans
votre circonscription d'enreg
heureusement c'est votre première
campagne électorale qu'est-ce qui vous
fait croire que vous pouvez l'emporter
là où je québécois en 2018 n'a pas pu le
faire
en 2018 n'avait pas pu l'emporter dans
Rosemont qu'est-ce que vous fait croire
que cette fois-ci vous êtes capable de
le faire oh ben c'est c'est du travail
le terrain en élection je vais avoir en
marchant sur le terrain avec tellement
de d'enthousiasme je pense que les les
gens qui sont qui sont pour la
souveraineté les pékistes sont très très
sont très présents en ce moment sur le
terrain puis ils veulent m'élite très
très fort je pense que c'est bon c'est
de bonne humeur pour le futur merci
beaucoup monsieur brillant merci
alors évidemment et vous allez entendre
mesdames et messieurs beaucoup pendant
qu'on voit que Manon m'a assez élu pour
un troisième mandat dans Sainte Marie
Saint-Jacques allons masser la cour
porte-parole de Québec solidaire ils
sont à 8 Québec solidaire je vous le
rappelle ils étaient à 10 avant et dans
Maurice Richard ils étaient en avance
ils traînent de l'arrière maintenant et
si la coalition Québec est à 92
circonscriptions en avance en ce moment
c'est notamment à cause de Maurice
Richard ou la carte est en avance par
197 voix mais aussi Enjou louis réel une
circonscription du Parti libéral où la
coalition Amiens Québec performe bien
donc il y a deux circonscriptions de
plus où ils sont en avance Camille
Laurens vous me permettez la carte est
en avance par 134 voix monsieur
Saint-Pierre pernandon le chef du PQ et
deuxième puis regardez ce qui se passe à
Laval il y avait cinq des six
circonscriptions qui étaient libérales
quand on regarde en 2018 5 des 6 c'était
général aujourd'hui avec les résultats
qu'on a c'est quatre des six qui sont
caquistes et dans sa la cinquième ici
Vimont c'est une avance de 150 voix sur
la candidate de la collection à Québec
donc pourquoi la carte est à 92
notamment Laval mais aussi à Montréal où
ils sont en avance dans deux
circonscriptions de plus que ce qu'ils
avaient en 2018
très bien on va voir la situation des
chefs bon évidemment monsieur Legault
était lu depuis longtemps Sainte Marie
et Sainte-Anne Dominique Anglade qui est
en avance pour l'instant dans Gouin
aussi ça devrait rapidement être une
formalité pour Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
Camille Laurin Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon qui traîne le moins là c'est
il traîne l'arrière donc il n'est pas
premier c'est pas 134 c'est contre lui
Eric duel même chose on rigide dans
Chauveau avec l'écart qui est là c'est
inatteignable ou à peu près
mathématiquement on voit des images du
rassemblement de la collection à venir
Québec Robert Bourassa en 89 avait eu 92
on est on est dans on est dans ces eaux
là au Parti libéral on voit des images
en direct
à 19
c'est inatteignable
des images de Québec solidaires
avec l'annonce de la victoire de Manon
Macé Québec solidaire qui frôle le score
qu'ils avaient eu en termes de nombre de
sièges par rapport à la dernière fois
[Applaudissements]
elle a aussi des images en direct du la
permanence du rassemblement du Parti
québécois
et le Parti conservateur et vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure le candidat dans
Rosemont du Parti québécois parler de la
réforme du mode de scrutin attendez-vous
attendent entendre ça beaucoup ce soir
chez les parties d'opposition en disant
Parti conservateur à deux à zéro pierre
on est à 12% du vol est-ce que ça allait
absolument nulle part
ça sert à rien de jouer dans ce film là
pendant une demi-heure ça arrivera pas
monsieur Legault il se livrait assez
député ah ouais on va faire une réforme
du mode de scrutin les amis il y en a 40
d'entre vous qui auront pas de siège
prochaine sélection c'est extraordinaire
comme proposition quand on veut gérer un
gros caucus et il a dit que la porte
était fermée
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur l'état de
l'opposition par contre tour de table la
partie
en termes de en terme de compter ça
reste à voir
les sondages à Port le PQ en termes de
pourcentage de sondage sont pas mal
dessus le reste c'est moins sûr c'est
pas l'effondrement que certains voyaient
pour le Parti libéral non ils ont une
grosse perte mais certains parlaient au
début de la campagne de 12 13 14 pour
les libéraux dans le pire des scénarios
pendant que on voit que Gabriel ado
Dubois bien sûr et réélu dans coin
Audrey Meurice c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour la carte parce que on le disait au
début la kak a besoin d'avoir des
personnes ministrables à la Ville de
Montréal elle est ministrable et si elle
devait être élu elle a joué un rôle
important pour représenter la Ville de
Montréal au Conseil des ministres
on va aller on va aller voir alexandre
Duval qui est avec Carlos Letta ou qui
était du président de cette campagne qui
avait fait son meilleur culpa pour le
cadre financier on vous écoute avec ça
écoutez alors Carlos
de voir que vous conservez ben en fait
quelle partie libéral conserve
l'opposition officielle mais tout de
même
s'apprête à avoir moins de sièges que ce
qu'il y avait au moment de la
dissolution comment vous percevez ça
pour nous c'était important de de garder
l'opposition cruciale parce qu'avec ça
il y a toutes sortes de de de de budget
toutes sortes de temps de parole à
l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est
important de faire ça et plus que ça ça
nous donne aussi maintenant le temps 4
ans pour Dominique parce qu'il faut que
Dominique reste et elle va rester pour
Dominique puisse rebâtir et recentrer le
Parti libéral pour qu'on soit prêt 2026
mais monsieur l'étape d'avoir quand même
moins de sièges ce soir que ce qui était
le cas à la dissolution est-ce que c'est
possible que quelque chose dans la
campagne de Madame Anglade qui n'a pas
fonctionné je vous dirai d'entrée de jeu
là on reconnaît absolument Flac campagne
a mal commencé la première semaine les
premiers dix jours
n'était pas bon disons-le comme ça donc
par la suite après le premier débat je
pense que Dominique a été capable
toujours en gardant une grande rigueur
et très bien centré sur ces sur ces
lignes et tout ça elle a réussi à nous
ramener et à reprendre ce qu'on avait
perdu on avait beaucoup baissé en
première moitié de campagne pensez-vous
que le manquait de temps je pense qu'il
a manqué de ça je pense que ça serait
pris encore peut-être une semaine et
surtout et étant donné ce que ce que la
carte était en train de faire monsieur
le gars qui disait toutes sortes de
choses sous l'immigration entre autres
donc si on avait eu encore une semaine
ça aurait été mieux vous avez dit
Monsieur létal elle va rester madame
englade sauf qu'elle fera face forcément
un vote de confiance c'est dans la
constitution du Parti libéral
pensez-vous vraiment que les militants
vont la laisser continuer quatre ans
alors qu'on est dans un creux pour le
Parti libéral avec le résultat de ce
soir EC moi je vais démarrer très actif
en partie libérale je fais partie de
plusieurs commissions et je vais rester
très engagé et je vais faire tout ce que
je peux utiliser toute l'influence que
j'ai encore reparti pour Dominique
DANGLADE reste chef de Paris c'est
important on a besoin qu'elle reste on a
besoin qu'elle
refasse le parti Carlos l'état merci
beaucoup alors Patrice vous l'entendez
la réaction de Dominique Anglade qui
viendra bien sûr plus tard quand elle
arrivera ici au Théâtre Corona dansé
Henri Sainte-Anne les militants étaient
pas trop surpris de la victoire rapide
de la CAQ ce soir reste très motivé
quand il y a des victoires libérales qui
sont annoncées mais bien entendu pour
Dominique Anglade ça reste un résultat
difficile
très bien merci merci beaucoup oui le
Parti libéral du Québec a fait lire 31
députés la dernière fois ils sont à 19
mais bon à 12 ce qui fait peut-être plus
mal encore si le pourcentage à 12% le
Parti québécois à 15 %, n'a que deux
députés en voie d'être élu enfin il est
il a été élu parce que Bérubé mais dans
oser de la Madeleine
ce n'est pas encore réglé regardez à Old
déjà ils avaient eu Gatineau lac Suzanne
Tremblay une boîte oui préliminaire
n'empêche elle est en avance sur la
députée sortante de Maryse Gaudreault
qui a beaucoup de racines à elle alors
on va on va voir on va suivre cette
course attentivement et
et pour expliquer la performance du
Parti québécois et dans la porte
pardonnez-moi Sébastien Isabelle le
poulet qui est en avance sur Mathieu
Gratton Nicole Ménard la libéral ne se
représentait pas ça porte le bastion
libéral depuis qu'on est jeune
Park c'est un château fort sur la
Rive-Sud normalement libérale qui
pourrait tomber ce soir laurier Dorion
sans surprise Fance est en avance sur
dans market Enrique
bon lui ça va bien c'est réglé pour ce
soir au tout début il y a eu un peu
chaud mais il conserve assez facilement
il va conserver assez facilement sans
compter dans Prévost Sonia Bélanger ça
c'est le comté de Marguerite Blaye qui
ne se représentait pas dans Laurentides
et il a kaki Sonia Bélanger qui a pris
le relais est en bonne voie d'être élu
ils Montigny dans René Lévesque ça c'est
il chasse le PQ
le chef Sébastien qui ne se représente
plus dans matter Wallet était un bon
terme c'est Sylvain royal qui s'était
chicané avec le chiffre
très bien
parlons de l'Est du Québec si vous vous
demandez pourquoi le Parti québécois à
15 % des votes en ce moment et seulement
deux circonscriptions il est en avance
c'est qu'il est deuxième dans 45
circonscriptions dans 45
circonscriptions au Québec actuellement
le Parti québécois et deuxième mais
c'est pas assez pour lui donner des
circonscriptions la coalition Québec à
90 passe la MAP dans l'Est du Québec
regardez ça ressemblait à quoi en 2018
ça ressemblait à ça en 2018 ça ressemble
à quoi en 2022 ça semble à ça avec
seulement matin de matteadia qui tient
le coup pour le Parti québécois les Îles
de la Madeleine que vous n'apercevez pas
sur cette carte là les gens avec des
yeux de lynx ont vu le PQ1 PQ 1 ça doit
être dans l'appeler ça chauffe ça change
d'un côté de l'autre
monsieur la chance du Parti conservateur
est en avance sur monsieur Kay dans les
7 circonscriptions de chaudière
Appalache le pcq est deuxième donc
performant compétitif dans la grande
région de Québec
intéressant intéressant parce que pour
eux entre 0 et 1 c'est entre
c'est toute la différence du monde c'est
le débat c'est être dans la vie
politique on le vit avec le
parlementaire les points de prince à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est énorme une
grande visibilité à l'Assemblée
nationale que d'avoir un député il y a
quelque chose de sain il y a quelque
chose qui est sain quand on est 12% dans
les sondages ont normalement on devrait
être représenté l'Assemblée nationale
d'une manière ou d'une autre
série c'est mieux de pas mettre l'argent
en banque
on n'est pas là
Monsieur kek se retourne un peu comme
lui contre lui parce que il dans les
dernières années c'était ça qui
clientèle une bonne partie est devenu
clientèle des conservateurs je pense que
ça fait du sens que jusqu'à maintenant
chez ces saisons verra des résultats
lavals
Christopher qui est réélu avec une forte
majorité deuxième mandat et les adjoint
parlementaire de sur le gros Olivier
vous êtes avec Michel Trottier qui
arrive deuxième libéral
exactement Patrice donc ici sur l'île de
Laval brisardement il y a quatre
candidats de la CAQ qui sont soit élus
soit en avance deux pour les libéraux et
en compagnie de Michel rothique qui a
été défait par Christopher ski dans
cette rose alors Monsieur Trottier
comment vous réagissez donc à cette
défaite ce soir ben écoutez on a 4G de
la défaite encore actuellement mais moi
je tiens à dire qu'encore 30 000 vues
vote à dépouillé optimiste de nature et
donc je vais attendre la fin de la
soirée pour ça par contre je tiens à
dire que pour les citoyens de Laval de
Sainte-Rose la démocratie a été gagnante
dans le débat d'idée qu'il y a eu dans
ce qui a été mis en place puis moi ce
que je trouve que le citoyen est gagnant
mais par contre je vais encore attendre
avant de concéder la défaite malgré
parce que quand même des historiques de
dehors quand vous conviendrez avec moi
qu'à Laval c'est tout un revirement de
situation la casque qui va détenir le
plus grand nombre de sièges actuellement
et oui sont en avance dans certains
compter mais par contre moi je vais
attendre pour voir parce que dans les
derniers il y a quand même eu des
remontées merci beaucoup alors voilà
Patrice chez les libéraux ce soir donc
on ne réalise pas l'ampleur de la
défense
qui va s'adresser à ces militants
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous savez que c'est comme ça
qu'on gagne
[Applaudissements]
tu veux que soldat vous le savez comme
moi c'est plus qu'un parti politique
c'est un mouvement c'est mon map ce
mouvement là c'est vous qui leur a
dépassé
[Applaudissements]
Jacques qui nous écoute
nous sommes Manon massique qui remercie
ces militants ils sont vous avez vu que
ça a bougé pour Québec solidaire
pourquoi ça a bougé je vous le montre
tout de suite dans Maurice Richard à
rude Boisy a repris en repris l’avance
c'est très très serré entre Audrey
Murray et
Haroun Boisy alors qu'est-ce qui est en
avance on va suivre ça ça risque André
funticila qui est en avance également
sur le libéral dans laurier d'Orient il
y a quand même une bonne avance et bon
on vient de le voir Maurice Richard 55
voix
Verdun on a des premiers chiffres dans
qu'on voit Rosemont vincent Marissal qui
est maintenant une confortable avance on
a une
monsieur boulet on l'écoute
les derniers jours
absolument mais je suis vraiment fière
pour utiliser un terme que vous
connaissez je suis fier d'être un très
fluvien qui je suis vraiment heureux de
la réaction des personnes qui ont apposé
un X dans mon contexte
la controverse autour de vos proches je
veux pas faire d'analyse ce soir l'heure
est à la à la fête je veux encore une
fois féliciter tous mes collègues de la
mort ici du Centre du Québec et du
Québec qui est à substinction était
déclarée gagnant moi je veux chez ici
pour être avec les militants militantes
et c'est ce qui m'importe pour l'instant
il y a encore plein de dossiers de
préoccupation dans nos comté dans la
région au Québec et je pense qu'on est
une équipe de personnes extrêmement
compétente pour continuer dans la même
monsieur boulet qui a dit on va
continuer est-ce que vous craignez à lui
a demandé est-ce que vous avez crainte
c'est un impact dans la regardant les
chiffres il dit il y a pas eu un grand
impact en tout cas
dans ma région et un peu partout au
Québec on a des chiffres pour Verdun oui
c'est construction de lui faire landaise
ce soir donc Verdun les premiers
chiffres on voit que Québec Solidaire
est en avance 19 boîtes de scrutin
dépouillés avance de 207 voix pour
Madame zagamendes sur la députés
sortante Isabelle mélanson ça va être
intéressant ah oui j'ai oublié de
regarder où était les la coalitions
Québec mais ils sont ils sont ils sont
quand même un peu loin pour peut-être
espérer avoir cette circonscription puis
dans Saint-Lary Sainte-Anne la
circonscription de Madame
Anglade et des temps en avance dans sa
circonscription monsieur
saint-pierre-lamandon est en déficit
dans la sienne et dans Maurice Richard
donc on l'a vu juste avant Québec
solidaire qui est en qui est en avance
également donc pour l'instant ils
auraient un gain en fait ces deux gains
là mais on des pertes ailleurs ceux qui
feraient un gain un gain absolu dans
Rouin je vais vous demander après
d'aller dans Rouen Sébastien dans
tâchereau réélu Étienne Grandmont élu
élu pardon dans tâchereau il remplace
Catherine Dorian Roy alors les voici les
résultats bon avance bon avance pour
Daniel Bernard de la CAQ qui était
député libérale qui a été conseillé
municipal jusqu'à tout dernierment et
qui est candidat de la CAQ ça il y en a
certaines qui vont faire plus plaisir à
monsieur Legault que d'autres celle-là
va certainement faire plaisir à monsieur
Legault madame sir tout à fait puis on
verra peut-être un peu plus tard pour
l'analyse j'aimerais aussi qu'on
souligne un gamin il y a quand même
42 bureaux de scrutin qui est 71 223
voies d'avance aussi pour Monsieur
Lamotte nous on peut parler d'une
certaine tendance mais je me garde un
petit jeune parce que j'étais encore tôt
par rapport au nombre de bois c'est très
bien dans Marwa risky réélu dans Saint
Laurent ça faisait pas de doute on lui
souhaite d'ailleurs
la meilleure des chances elle est on
nous disait
en train de donner naissance à un enfant
alors c'est merveilleux félicitations
vincent Marissal relu d'un Rosemont pour
Québec solidaire c'est réglé c'est
bouclés dans le cas de QS à Rosemont et
rouba Gazal également dans Mercier
l'ancienne circonscription d'Amir cadire
dans Mercier donc Sherbrooke qu'est-ce
que se passe pendant Alexandre Leduc
réélu dans Hochelaga Maisonneuve
deuxième mandat pour Monsieur Leduc dans
Sherbrooke dans Sherbrooke ça tient au
Québec solidaire au moment où on se
parle dans un océan de bleu poudre avec
534 bois d'avance pour Christine Labrit
sur Caroline St-Hilaire vraiment une
bataille à finir entre les deux mais
pour l'instant Québec solidaire semble
avoir le dessus dans cette bataille pour
Sherbrooke saint François oui
Saint-François c'est une circonscription
qu'on regardait pas de pas de débat ici
dans Saint-François
2100 presque 2200 voix d'avance pour la
député sortante contre une candidate
quand même de qualité Mélissa généreux
la directrice de la santé publique
parlons-en c'est ça qui c'est ça qui
fait mal à Québec solidaire on voulait
sortir de l'île si on avait une bonne
soirée on pouvait être encore plus
compétitif dans Saint-François on a une
soirée ordinaire au Québec solidaire
reste beaucoup de vote à Montréal
pourcentage va bouger mon nombre de
sièges on pensait être capable d'aller
chercher deux trois quatre sièges de
plus que les disques qu'on avait à la
dissolution fallait aller chercher
Saint-François ce sera pas le cas avec
une avance comme celle-là donc
certainement une petite déception parce
qu'on avait une bonne candidate alors
les sondages montré que c'était plus
serré que ce qu'on voit ce soir donc